H J o with the pants.
Anjo pants hand John.
Did he just make that up? I'm just
waiting for the right fucking time.
That's hilarious. All Right
Ladies and gentlemen, this
is now where it's official.
Yeah, I said it sounds
professional. Someone who
said, I have a radio voice. Oh,
Donald Cowboy was like, uh, I, you got a
radio voice and that's your radio voice.
Donald Cowboy Cerrone.
He's a guy fights in the UFC and he was
here for the podcast the other day and
he sent me, accused me of having
a radio voice. Now think about it.
Fuck do I even delicate voice.
Why is that a bad thing?
That's a compliment.
Well,
I recognize that the instrument
has a bunch of different
sounds that it can make.
What is, what is one of the reasons why
I appreciate music? I appreciate music.
I mean,
I've told you the guys this before,
like one of the things I love about
what you guys do is I have zero talent.
Like I love something that I have now.
Like where I don't know anything about it.
I love music. I'm a huge
fan. I know nothing about it.
When you guys started talking about
bars and notes and I'm like Blah Blah.
I have no idea where you're
saying we don't either.
Do you, are you like, cause
you use her voice a lot,
you know when you're on stage and you use
it in different registers and, and you,
you know, you podcasts. Do you like,
have you ever had problems with it? No.
That's amazing.
Screaming too.
I know you hear a lot of Comedians,
I think. Well you could do it
without fucking use your thing up.
Well the UFC is the weirdest one.
I fucking scream sometimes.
I don't even know I'm doing it in Tom
doing it. Like sometimes I'm standing up,
I don't even know him up.
Like I'm standing up, I'm
doing cart. Like there was a,
our Lawsky um, and um, uh,
Travis Brown fight this crazy fight
between these two giant guys who are
painting the fuck out of each other.
They kept getting dropped like over
into like our Laskey dropped him,
but I think three times and he kept
getting up and then he dropped our Lawsky.
And there are lot of came back and knocked
him out and by the end of the fight I
was standing up screaming
and I just shut it off.
I had to realize I didn't
and my pants first,
I didn't know I was up until I was like,
well was fucking standing up.
I don't even know. I've, I've only
done that a couple of times, right.
Just all of a sudden I'm standing.
Okay.
The fact that you can scream and you don't
lose your voice I think is remarkable
because it's like,
I bet back when I was bartending,
I lose my voice all the time just from
trying to, you know, raise your volume.
And so yeah. But when I,
when I quit bartending,
my voice went up like an octave and I had
it, but I had to go to speech therapy.
So I learned all these things about
like how old were you back then?
Was that when you set up an octave,
does them, is that like there's a,
an actual nurse for singing?
I wasn't like speaking in enough that
well those old ladies that you
hear about by the old bar lady,
who's that girl sue Bob from the whites
of West Virginia, they Budweiser. Boy.
I always been the sexy one in the family.
If you've ever seen that,
you haven't seen it. Oh God. Oh my God.
No, you've never seen it. Never went.
The wonderful whites of West Virginia
got everyone talks about, oh my top two.
Tell us about this mosque.
Nashville.
Everybody required viewing.
Who wants to be seen?
You can't shut the fuck up about it. Yeah.
Cause you're like, Yo, I think it was,
wasn't Johnny Knoxville was
it his amazing, amazing.
It's just a really well done documentary.
Not just freaky people,
but it's all that bar, that bar
voice. They got that bar votes.
Yes.
Sega ranch and Jeremy and cigarettes.
Booze and yelling and there's a,
there's a sexiness to it though. There's
like, there's definitely like a, Oh wow,
that person has fun. You know,
and I, I, I've definitely like I,
I like having a raspy voice but
also like no, that it's just damage.
So I'm not super pumped about it.
At the same time,
really attracted to voices like that.
In general though.
You listen like Otis Redding. Yeah.
He's got a battered fucking voice. Yeah.
Janice Joplin. How about Petkoski?
Okay. That was of his half of his thing.
Barn and do this. Yeah. When
you trust that this thing like,
oh yeah, yeah, but I also think
it was his like good way of thing.
It's like some people have that incredible
ability to like channel there person
through this incredible voice like
Bukovsky or something like that and like,
you know,
so they're easier to listen to.
Well, bootcamp skis, poems were
always just raw and interesting,
but there are nothing like when he
read them, especially when you saw it,
there's like for him,
he's one of the rare poets that I think
the visual aspect like enhances it
significantly. Like, I would love
one of my favorite, uh, there's a, a,
a bunch of videos of him,
uh,
at like these readings and he would sit
in front of these audiences and we drink
wine and knew would get fucked up.
And if people were talking,
you would yell at them,
I'll come over there right now and
I'll beat the fucking shit out of you.
And he was this old drunk man,
but he was just,
and he really would have Donna
theaudience and fought people.
And then he would read this like really
intense stuff that he wrote about life
and mortality and his, you
know, vision of humanity.
It's so hard to get people
to care about poetry.
So I think that's how you do it,
kind of. It's Adam, you Kinda,
you're taking such a crazy chance
to even say you wrote a poem.
They tell someone hammering
home, nobody goes, yeah,
the fucking awesome dude.
That's,
he knows most of the time when someone
says, uh, I've, uh, wrote a poem,
I'd like you to read it. Like, Nah.
Like if someone says they have a song,
I'm like, oh, I love songs. Someone says,
Dude, or the best joke, oh, I can't
wait to hear it. I got the best poems,
poems, it. Sure. Oh Man. Right.
The best poet of the bore and the
best poem is a chore. The best,
the very best little poetry right there.
Just write
the small work and lay that shit on us.
But when people,
when there is a visual element,
it's amazing. You know,
Spalding gray. Yeah, yeah.
That's,
yeah.
Ooh, I don't remember. I don't know.
But he did that swimming to Cambodia
stuff and it's him telling these stories
and it's really poetic. Um, I'm not,
but it's a storytelling element.
You don't all of a sudden we want to
listen to, I want to listen to it.
I think it's fucking, how about Eric
Bogosian? I Dunno who that dude is. He,
I think, um, I think, yeah,
Spalding gray. I did do that.
He was having some health issues
and he wound up killing himself.
But Eric [inaudible] goes,
he was a guy who, um,
actually he was doing like more
like one man shows. Well that goes,
you always had a bunch of
movies for a while, but he,
he actually did some acting too,
but he did like these one man show
things I want to see. He was a reading,
I want to say. They were like really
well done readings too that he did.
But Spalding gray was guy was
like more known for it. Right.
Cause he sat down at the table.
Yeah.
He had his desk and even had like a real
theatrical vibe lights would be going
on.
Yeah.
It's sad when you hear about a garlic
that killed himself cause you're like fuck
dude.
You know all these people liked you
when he died. Well he was famous
enough that we're talking about yeah.
And that community,
I'm sure he's,
he was reasonably well known for sure.
And at the time he had
been on TV quite a bit,
which is where Ben and I
probably saw him first. Right.
That's why I'm on the Youtube.
Um, cause he had got series,
like who's the filmmaker?
Um,
guy did a lot of concert films and
I can't remember his name right now,
but in the 60s he was,
he was at like a,
he was taking Hendricks footage and he
was taking a lot of festival footage in
the 60s, which nobody was really doing
at that time. Or at least nowhere near
the rounder stuff. Lomax
Lomax. No, he was molded great.
I think his heyday was like the 80s,
late seventies,
like swimming to Cambodia was 87 but
who's the guy who did the film with
Cambodia who directed it and see
here, hold on cause he did this. Um,
I think the Toronto Peace
Festival, this fucking amazing.
Jonathan Demi. Demi. Yeah.
I swear you go home. You're faster than
me. Bastard. I have it too. It was trying.
Yeah. Um, yeah. So you, yeah, that was a,
he was apparently it was about
his participation in the movie,
the killing fields. I didn't know that
he had anything to do with that. Yeah.
When all these beautiful stories,
I mean it's not much about the production,
it's about his experiences.
He just Kinda like took shit pretty,
he was an extreme or kind of like a
radical liver right now and just a great
storyteller,
which is super rare I think.
I mean it seems like mainly that rent,
that's kind of the comedians realm now.
Like people don't give a shit
about storytellers, but people,
if you're a comedian you
could tell us a story. Well,
I think in a way the problem
is like trying to sell this
just like we're talking
about like selling poetry,
selling a guy who's like doing
a one man show or one man story.
It's hard but essentially
like a lot of podcasts
are like that. Yeah,
we're stand up, stand up,
stand up can be anything and
a lot of ways, yeah, but the,
I think the idea about standup as
though you're going to try to be as self
indulgent,
like only you,
you try to be as little
self indulgence possible.
I'm that's the wrong way of phrasing
that does the least amount of self
indulgent humanly possible and the most
amount of entertainment for the people
that are listening to the most
amount of self deprecation,
the most amount of laughs
that you can get out of it.
The most amount of humility and approach
to the lab so you don't make people
uncomfortable.
Like there's all these
variables in achieving the
laugh and achieving the laugh
is like the proof that you're on the
same level and then they appreciate your
sincerity and then you're,
you're funny and you're hilarious.
That's all working together.
So it's all like this,
like dance that you're
doing to achieve a result,
whereas you don't have to have a real
result with one of these fucking things.
You know what I mean? Would
have, you would think,
but the amount that aren't like to
get it to that polished diamond state
requires a lot of disciplines. But how
am I saying about stand up, stand up.
You eat dick on stage. It just
balances it out. You can't,
it's just too hard. The bombing
was too hard on the soul. You'll,
you'll come around to writing
the best shit you can. That's it.
Did I really think there's a level of
bravery and stand up that is not really
involved in music.
People just don't judge you the same
way you know thing to quantify because I
think there's a level of
bravery and being a soldier,
that's a lot tougher than the lower there,
but none of those people are here deeper
and deeper though. You know what I mean?
There's your referral of bravery
when Krogers save the earth either.
You're right.
I mean just always going to be,
everybody makes their effort
in a different way, you know?
Definitely the physical structure
to be a soldier and the brain power,
emotional power. Do you think you'd
go over and kick some ass for America?
I think,
I think I could
save myself not to Cincinnati.
I'm not wearing parts of Ohio
national guard.
All of America since
Cincinnati and Cleveland.
Did they have a rivalry at all?
Like if you said gas for Cleveland does
people in Cincinnati or they're going to
hate on you now and
next time you're there,
it's really Kentucky versus Bangles
browns versus Steelers Brown's versus
ravens. Those are the, that's the
Trifecta of difficult times in,
in that region of the country.
But I'll be honest with you,
I love playing in Pittsburgh.
I love playing in Cincinnati
and every time I'll have fun,
harmless banter about our sports teams.
We say the same about Baltimore as
much as like Baltimore is a great town,
but we only really went through there
once and we literally stopped to eat
dinner and found crack on the ground.
We've got to build belts.
I know,
but we want to come play there and
get help us have to take some time.
Don't be a hero.
We're talking about the amount of
bravery it takes to be a comedian.
Pretty radically. Baltimore.
I had this guy, Michael Wood,
who was a cop from Baltimore,
had him on the podcast. Oh Wow.
He was a retired cop and a young guy too,
you know,
just a massive shoulder injuries.
Shoulder blew apart.
They put it back together and and
blue a party and he had to retire,
but very intelligent,
articulate dude and very compassionate
and outside of the police department now
you know, still a young guy. What was
he like 35 or something like that?
Maybe younger. Did he get shot?
I forget what the injury was,
but he had to get shoulder
reconstructive surgery and then it still,
it still didn't take and it
was like a shoulder's fucked.
Like he apparently was in a high speed
chase and shoulder just blew out,
was turning the steering wheel.
It's pretty, it's pretty fucked up.
But point is like he was talking about
how crazy Baltimore has always been.
If they found some directives,
I guess it was from the police
department from the 1970s. And he's like,
me and these other cops are reading
this. We're like, Jesus fucking Christ,
we're running,
we're chasing our tails.
Like this is exactly the same places
where the exact same crimes are going on.
There's a specific reason for that.
And that's because there
was like literal like,
like constitutional or
like city ordinances of,
of segregation and,
and consolidating these neighborhoods
and having them be specifically black and
you couldn't buy a house in a certain
neighborhood if you were black,
even if you had the money, you
know, it's, it's the whole,
it's the whole tier is like,
they were just built to fail.
And the reason that crime was flourishing
and thriving so much is because they
didn't have a fucking chance.
I mean, it's like the, uh,
I listened to NPR podcasts a little
while ago that explained how,
um,
when w was it,
the 60s boom is post war post
World War Two, post World War II,
these housing ordinances for the vets
and things like that. And they're like,
hey guys, welcome back. You can't live
here. It's pretty brutal. It's awful.
It is pretty awful.
I didn't even know about that until
a few years ago and it seems like,
who do you remember who brought that up?
Someone brought that up on the podcast
and we like what we had to look into it.
Do you remember who it was, Jim? No,
it's the same with education too.
I mean it would be like
all of these, um, you know,
schools that just wouldn't let
intelligent African-american's in and you
wouldn't get the education that you
wanted or deserved or know could achieve.
And it was just like, you know,
you're kind of stuck in this box,
which is those neighborhoods, you know,
they were, they were made for that.
It's total, it's so fucked up. There's
so many levels to the whole thing.
Like first of all,
the level of overcoming slavery.
Like you ever heard a white guy
saying, God, it was so long ago,
fucking get over it.
You know the Jews, I've,
I've heard white guys say that
and you go, okay, it's not
that long. A hundred years before what
she was just talking about it. Yeah.
It seems like it was long.
Like I have a 1965 corvette
when that corvette,
when it was made a hundred years
before that almost exactly.
Slavery was abolished.
That's fucking crazy.
That's insane. Yeah. That might
be one of the most bizarre things.
A hundred years is not my,
my wife's mom died recently.
She was 97 like she was
a hundred years old. Wow.
So from the time did she died too?
Like,
like realistically she could have been
alive while fucking slavery is happening.
Oh my God. Yeah. I mean it's real
listed. Like that amount of age.
You could have someone from 1965 and they,
if they were that age they could
remember fucking slavery. Yeah.
That's terrible. Oh God. God
Damn. That's like when I was born,
I was born in 67 so I was
born two years after that.
Like that is to me when I put it in
those terms, like the generational terms,
it was yes.
Today. Yeah. People had
slaves yesterday and all the,
when they still do some places now.
I mean this is just start kind of like
this that's going on all we were just
talking about nail salons,
something that we found out, it's,
it's really disturbing
is that, um, you know,
there's like a diamond dozen nail salons
in New York City or places like la
where it's really cheap to get your toes
and your fucking years painted and it
was really good. But there's, there's
all, there's this like there's a,
wow, you're so, um, he would go
and he was put together by the way.
You are missing a button and I can
see your belly button. Whoa. Hey,
I want to have a problem with that. And
again, I don't have a problem yet. No,
but they were these nail salons,
they bring in men and women,
um, from, you know, Thailand,
Vietnam and they're like indentured
servants and then make them work and they
don't pay them. And they, they
live in these apartments with,
with like 15 people sleeping in one room
and like, it's all going to Shit Misha.
Hmm. Yeah. How do they fix
that? It's a real good question.
I think in this like what
you can control for sure.
First is in this country, you know,
I mean things like, uh, what I,
we talked about before the show about
my friend Justin wren and all these,
a little artifacts he brought back
back from the Congo like that guys like
changing things in like real time.
But like in this country I think there's
a bunch of things that could be done
that are just not done.
Sure.
One of the major ones is they have
to treat really poor neighborhoods.
Not like a static reality that had,
it just is what it is,
is a really poor neighborhood.
They have to put it like as a problem,
like a wildfire. Like here you got a
wildfire, what are you going to do?
You can just kind of let it burn
and just get out of the way.
Or are you going to put it out?
You get the, you have a problem,
you have a let the electricity's down,
you have a, you know, whatever. Oh,
a watermain broke. You have a
PR, there's a problem. Yeah.
But those have such direct, you know,
maybe that's what's so difficult about,
it's like put the put water on a fire,
it's going to go out. This is like God,
the implications on that stuff.
It's so crazy.
I think they should admit
first and foremost that a
horrible crime has been done
in places like Baltimore when they,
you know what this is,
Michael would describe it
as institutionalized racism
and we talk about the
zones where people live. It's
hard to argue against that. So,
and then you have to feel,
then you have to think about like,
what is the best way to uh,
help people out of this?
What's the best way to engineer like a,
a more crime free,
safer,
more educated and aware and the more,
and the people have these people feel
like they belong as part of the rest of
the city. Yeah. To do that without
its collection efforts. I mean, yeah,
it's, it's something like, it's really,
I'm really glad we're talking about
this because I think like this,
this kind of thing like keeps me up at
night when I think about like, like fuck,
what can, what can I do? What can we
do? You know, you write a poem about it.
We want to hear it. Listen
Motherfucker, I had a poem right now,
like I'm going to start,
wait, but things like Joe, like
your podcast are, are Balkan.
Pat, you like your fucking dog.
I'm serious though. Like this,
this kind of thing is part of that
collective effort is as giving people that
first grain of thought of like,
Oh wow,
I never knew that there were zoning laws
in Baltimore and inner cities that made
it really hard for black people to
get ahead in life that they had no
scholarships. You know, Pete,
the changes that need to be,
that need to take place.
Like we don't have some kind of solution,
you know like this think tank.
But you have this platform where
you can start talking about it and,
and informing people. And you know,
when I, when I get really worked up and,
and, and think about like,
what can we do? You know,
we have this band that is growing
and getting attention and you know,
you have these opportunities to sit
here and talk to somebody like you and
people are listening and you know,
you hope that that starts more another
train of thought that can actually make
some kind of different,
I don't know what it is.
I think people are already
having these conversations.
And one of the things that they love
about podcasts like this is because,
you know, you go, yes, other people were
thinking like this too. Like people are,
people are wondering,
how did we get to be grown adults with
this chaotic system in place that was
established by people who,
you know,
when you go back to the origins of
civilization, even just in this country,
which is at like a really recent country,
those people are monsters.
Those people
are monsters.
Oh man,
the fucking hammer lumbers had done.
Oh my God,
we're monsters.
Like, and this isn't, yeah, that's fucked
up. I just read this book about, um,
the first,
uh,
like the first interactions between
the West or mainly or in Europe
and Japan.
You know,
when the journeys that these people
would have to go through to trade to make
contact with these countries.
And I mean it's the way they looked at
the world then was the way we look at the
universe now it's just like,
I don't know what's over there.
I have no idea what's going on.
There's things Johnny,
there's icebergs jutting out of the water
and monsters that eat people like in
cannibals and shit. Like that was real,
you know, so it's like this super,
I think climate of defensiveness
that we all add just as a person,
you grow up kind of trying to defend
yourself against the environment,
high level. And then Mac Nellie's
takes off, sorry, go ahead.
There's just a layer of danger that
at least where we are, you know,
accustomed to. So you're going around
the world being like, holy fuck.
Like where am I? I don't want to get
killed. 50% of my man just died. You like,
you know it's,
I don't know.
I don't know what I'm trying to say
other than the context is so different.
You know it's,
it's
totally different world.
That's why it's insane to live our,
to have our civilization run the way
it's run now just because it's been done,
done this way for a hundred
plus 200 plus whatever years.
Like if we wanted to start out today,
how many people would think would
accept the electoral college?
How many people would accept the
idea that you actually just elect a
representative and that representative
can actually like he can choose to vote
against the wishes of the rest
of the state. Like you can,
you have like a electoral
college and then you have a win.
Each state has a certain amount of
points that go in and you watch the,
when you watched a v like that, like how
many votes is what and what's going on,
the numbers are in and what
the fuck are you talking about?
And then you find out that like,
especially during like the George Bush
days and they were still doing it with a
piece of paper with a whole,
and that piece of paper
that was,
when was in that,
like the 90s when the election
was recalled because it was,
there was,
they
count well to this day people
still believe Al Gore won. Yeah.
There's a lot of people that believe
he won and that they fucked him out of
Florida.
And it was also like how would we did
some weird shit where they like they just
crossed people's names out and ban them
if they thought they were black and then
they would have to prove that they
weren't the person that that was a off the
this list of like Fallons or you know
like sometimes people, Jimmy White,
there's a lot of fucking Jimmy
wide span. You know, if you're,
if you're Jimmy White and you live in
Baltimore and there's a thousand of the
Jimmy Whites and 20 of
them had been to jail,
like good luck getting registered to vote,
they're going to put
you on a fucking list.
And then you have to go to court to
like make sure that you can vote.
It takes too much time. They're not
going to do it. No one's going to do it.
Then all of the time for that and
they know that they rigged it,
which is just dark. Here's the
thing, it's like an American,
this system is flawed. I mean there's
just no fucking two ways around it.
I just don't think it
needs to be here anymore.
I think it's like one of those things
like you need to write books on paper with
ink.
You need a quill and you just shit a no,
you don't need a sieve. I Candela. You
don't need to write with a feather.
You can talk and your computer will
dictate it were brand new world and this
world of, it's hard to get
information across to the states,
so you need a representative.
He need, you can't eat that.
You want to make sure that every area,
even the high population areas,
they don't dominate the rural farm lands.
So we need to have some sort of system
where people give a fuck about Iowa.
I mean, that's really what it is. But
that's that. That's the only place,
because it was all established
when people were apes,
but we were raft riding
a bus with no cars. Yeah.
They didn't have phones that didn't know
where the fuck you went when you went
out of sight. If you went into the
woods, if they thought you were a dream.
People didn't even know if
they ever really did know.
They fucking really knew for
sure that you were coming back.
They make a painting of you
think about that.
Yeah.
Thanks.
That was it.
I remember the guy from the
writing shit that's cool.
On the cave was like an eight.
It was like an eight track
[inaudible] we were just in old town.
We were just an old town San
Diego yesterday after we played.
We played in San Diego yesterday
afternoon. And you go, God, I love it.
Sounds pretty pretty. You know, it's
pretty charming. But they had like, I,
you know what, I was so hungry and
I was like walking by in passing,
but they had like costumes,
um, like San Diego, San Diego,
like settlers,
you know.
But they like looked like pirates and
they were walking in the streets and um,
people were freaking out. They were
like, well, maybe there was a bus.
There were like two big buses of tourists.
I'm going crazy.
Like I was, I was like, I was like, God
dammit. Everybody calmed down. Jesus,
it's just a guy with a Cape
on fucking slow your roll.
But it was, um, it was funny. Well,
just kind of piggybacking and what we're
talking about because I'm thoroughly
obsessed with, um, like frontier
shows like deadwood. Oh,
and I'm watching hell on wheels right now.
I just got into this show how on wheels?
It's on AMC and it's,
it's really, it's really well
written. I'm only in like season two,
so I don't know what happened
after this guy's like,
I don't know if this is like blow the
forest statement, but it's still going.
So that says something bad about,
it's, it's about, um, this,
this railroad that's being
built. Uh, the, and like, it's,
it's incredible to be privy to
that that day and age where like,
it's so wild.
It's so lawless.
Everybody is just like barely
staying alive. You're like,
Indians are coming in killing you
and slaughtering you. You know,
you're like taking over their shit.
And it's really,
for some reason it just cuts
right to my soul. Like I can't,
I can't not be just totally enamored and
you know, enthralled by it and it like,
it's, it's interesting to
think about because that also
wasn't that long ago. No,
the,
the frontier days when the country
focus solely on this one thing together,
you know,
building this country,
well maybe not together because there's
so many immigrants in so many people
that were like isolated and,
but the point is that like,
it's interesting to witness everyone
fighting their battle, you know? But the,
there's these great parts of the show
when they all have to come together for a
common purpose.
Like there's robbers robbing the train
that gets them their pay and if they
don't get their pay,
they're broke. You know?
So there's like this
interesting camaraderie and
then their enemies and then you
know, and that's kind of how it is
in real life, you know, which is,
which is interesting to
think about because we're
all so different and you know
when you have these efforts,
and I don't want to say common enemy
because that sounds really negative,
but like when you're all working
towards something with your differences,
that's when actual
progress starts being made.
Right. That's, that's always a good
scene in the movie, right? Yeah.
To get seen as she can with the neighbors
to fight the monsters. Mel Gibson. Yeah.
How long
exactly what watching
Terminator Terminator two.
Isn't that really why we get so angry
and offended when people whine and bitch
today? Because like you're
like, good fucking Lord.
You live in the best time ever.
Society's going to shit. No,
it's good to be humble role.
It's fucking falling apart. Okay.
Nunez and he values anymore.
No one values culture or art.
Will you please stop saying that
everyone then we're just dealing with
overwhelming numbers of people
yelling in a room. That's what it is.
It's not that there's not as much or
way more interesting shit in that noise.
It's just there's so many fucking
people communicating now. Crazy. Yeah.
It's the whole rule. The, the, the,
the whole game is a different thing.
Everyone talks now. Yeah. Yeah.
Well,
you know what's,
you know what's super cool is like getting
people outside of their comfort zone
and watching how they deal with
it in like a, a way that like,
so like my folks live in Ohio,
pretty Republican,
you know, but they're really good people
on there. They're fucking hilarious.
And they came out to five shows in
Colorado on this last tour that we had
constant. It was, oh my God,
it was so Joe, it was talking
so close to smoking weed.
Yeah. My Dad, my dad just retired.
Just, it was just like a slow,
a ginger backing out was there
to help. It was, so my dad,
my dad's got a super thick Cleveland
acts and he's like, if I'm going to,
if I'm going to smoke pot with my daughter
and it's legal, I'm going to do it.
And it's just like, what did, I didn't
do it right. And I was like, well,
it ain't no weed. I mean, I was
like, right, you look great.
You gotta take it slow now
what you're getting into,
but I'll make sure it got like,
that doesn't drown,
but I want to tell you this fucking cool
thing. Which was that like, you know,
I love my parents so much and they're,
they're really incredible people and
I've watched them grow in this way that
like they're always changing.
And there they,
even though they have like
their beliefs and my dad is,
has worked his fucking ass off his life,
you know, and he, he's, uh, you know,
middleclass business owner just
retired. So he's got this, you know,
this view on life. And then we,
we put them in Colorado and he,
they caravan for five shows in this.
We had, we had lunch with this, um,
with these incredible people,
this, uh, this judge, this lawyer,
and he's like, you know, kind
of liberal Hippie, um, you know,
politicians in Colorado. And we, oh,
we were sitting at a table
with my parents and I was just,
it was so cool to watch them interact
with people that they would never hang out
with and, and then watch them sort
of like lay back and have like,
just like absorb this information
that's not something that they wouldn't,
they would have on a regular basis.
And so they, they left. And it was,
it was such an interesting,
like I really felt our relationship
changed a little bit after that, you know,
and just watching them let lose my
dad really wanted to smoke weed,
but it just never worked out.
He did what he had to drive and that
was responsible cause he would have been
fucked up.
Do you think like
gotten more successful and
as you've gotten older,
your dad can look at you
not just as his daughter,
but also as an adult human being
where he respects your opinion?
Oh yeah. Yeah. No, we're, we're,
we're very, um, we are like, no,
we have a really incredible relationship.
What did she say?
I said so,
so we're not there yet.
Well,
a meal ticket. No, I would love to take
care of nothing wrong with that. Yeah.
Beautiful. But, but I mean,
you're a woman now and you're
like a professional singer
of a like of the utmost
respect. Lay people live. Love
Your Shit. So it's like you, she,
he goes to see you and he sees her.
He sees his daughter on stage wailing
out these songs and people going nuts.
You don't think that must
make him think like, Whoa,
I gotta I gotta appreciate
like what it took to do that.
I have to appreciate what's happening
here. Like this isn't just my daughter.
She doesn't just have to listen to me.
She's not like,
I'm not right about everything.
I can't be right about
everything cause I can't do that.
No, we, he's both my mom
and my dad are really, uh,
they,
their support like is,
is beyond anything I ever could
have wanted. I mean they, they, uh,
I moved to New York City when I
was 16 because, um, I used to be a,
I was a catalog model and I was doing
really well and my parents were like,
I was starting my junior year
of high school and they were,
I was really fucking driven.
Like I had no inhibitions and I was like,
I want to go here and I want to go here
and do you guys think I can do that?
And they were like, yeah. And they, and
they let me move there when I was 16. Wow.
And it was fucking crazy.
And it honestly was one of those,
I think kind of pivotal moments where it,
it was their belief in the fact that
I could do what I wanted cause they,
they were like, I think you have
something special, you know,
which is like a really
incredible feeling to have.
And they were always behind
me and like, yeah, we fight.
I mean my family is really close so we
fight hard. There's a lot of yelling.
I grew up with a lot of yelling,
but
I know,
I know a lot of fucking memory lane.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
This is going to happen at some point.
We'll talk all about you got a baby.
Fuck him.
Hello baby steps.
Can we find another baby steps,
baby steps, another word in there.
You know what I'm saying though?
He across like even though it was,
it sounds like an inappropriate statement,
but you know what I'm saying,
the innocence
like see,
you know these
ray was, had, had to think
quite ludes in the 70s.
Well that's a problem too,
right? You start thinking like,
I want to be that loser again.
You know, down a tunnel. I'm sure
you also realize, hey, this does not,
this isn't go with success.
This doesn't help me, uh,
get my shit together and not be
psychologically terrified most of the day
looking around for my next fix of
Qualia foods. They were human though.
Like my mind's smoke weed. My Dad
used to smoke weed and like, Yo,
we're going to Ben,
we're going to do this.
I think there's a bad idea or
it might be amazing. I mean,
my dad's 94
four oh nine perfect.
What are you holding back cancer?
What are you worried about
that? Well, my 94 is convince.
Convincing man, maybe you're
right. 94 is the home stretch.
He might freak the fuck
out. No, but he might not.
He might like ease slowly into the great
beyond two or three year old man to go
from a pot to mushrooms.
They say that mushroom six is significant
reliever of the stress of worrying
about the expectation.
I'm so glad you just said it.
I've never even thought about with
him, you know? But he has anxiety.
He's freaked out. He's been
staring at the void dude for real.
He's seen his body deteriorate.
All these things happening and
I get the anxiety from them.
It's a real issue with
people, man. You know,
when we were kids and we would see what
we would call and quotes the angry old
man, you know, fucking kids.
And we always thought like,
God, it's got such a downer. Everybody
has them. Every neighborhood has a guide.
Poisoned the cats evil motherfucker.
Yeah.
He put a rat poison and killed a
bunch of cows. Forgot his name.
He's long gone though. Of
course. Of course. Yeah.
Every neighborhood has like old people
that are angry and one of the things that
they're angry at,
it's like the vitality of their vessel
is eroding before their eyes and you just
get caught up in this shit.
And
that's when you meet old people that
hate young people. Yeah. You know,
that was Elizabeth Bathory, I think it
was. Is that what her name? I don't know.
One of the most evil women
of all time. She was a, a,
a royal all imports is in New Orleans.
There was a crazy long time ago.
It was, no, it was in, it was in like,
I want to say Hungary is Beth.
Um,
but she's like one of the most famous
serial killers of all time. Oh Shit.
And what she started doing
after she started getting older,
she started killing all these young women
that were in the town and she would,
uh, she would like bathe and
their blood and she would,
she would torture them. Yeah. It
was in the 1500 hundreds in Hungary.
1516 Elizabeth Bathory.
Oh.
And she apparently is like attractive
when she was younger and then as she got
older, her appearance
fading beauty, snow, White,
Kinda [inaudible] away. I mean, it's just,
it's a scary fucking story because
she was a royal, she was a,
a very wealthy royal person,
so she never,
her punishment was just stay in your
castle. Yeah, she killed a lot of people.
Might've been like hundreds of
women or something. Oh yeah,
it was hundreds and they just, they just
made her stay in her castle. That was it.
That was the punishment.
I think the,
she like a special room that she had
to stay in and our castle, I mean,
so hot kind of jail I guess. But
I mean, she still had her money.
She still had servants.
That's kind of how it is now.
Just in a very different way.
Like people that are on top can get away
with so much like this fucking heavy.
Have you seen the Robert Durst
stuff on Hbo? I haven't seen it,
but I know about it. Gotten
pretty far. One would say,
and now he's kind of fucked himself
and it's looking like hopefully fingers
crossed. Um, you know, he'll, he's
going to go to jail. He's in jail.
He should be dead
pretty soon.
So apparently I was incorrect.
She, at the end of her life,
they put her in solitary confinement,
so she wasn't a castle,
but she was placed in solitary.
She kept,
she was kept bricked into a set
of rooms with only small slits up,
left open for ventilation
and the passing of foods.
She remained there for four years until
her death. So she was psychotic anyway.
And then they trapped.
She was a voter in like a black room.
She was a rich monster, which she was.
She was a privileged, rich monster.
And at the end she was such a monster
when they found what she had done,
that they found the bones
of these hundreds of women
and they knew that she had
been doing it forever.
And the servants knew when she bring
girls in and they would be screaming and
she would cut them up in front
of everybody and tie him up and,
and like feel tubs with their blood
and the throw their bodies aside.
And she had it.
She did it for a long fucking
famous woman in New Orleans is a house
you can go to. And she was just, you know,
member.
There's Times in American horror story,
I don't know,
but it's just like a famous story
you want to go either. No, I
don't. Not Interested in that.
It's just so scary.
It's so scary where people can get
to a fan of a position of ultimate
[inaudible]. They have a slave, they
have a, you know, if they have a royalty,
like if you've seen what's going on in
Los Angeles with all these guys from the
Middle East that keep doing
crazy things and they're,
they're getting arrested and they're
claiming diplomatic immunity.
Like that was the weapon bringing
it back to the lethal weapon. Sorry.
But that was like a big part of that
movie was that Diplomatic Immune African
guy. Oh yeah. Yeah. That's really
neat. I didn't even see say
11. It was from other movie has
been a bunch of them lately.
One guy was uh,
the uh,
the two guys fled the country because they
were racing through Beverly hills. Oh,
I did hear when they tried to claim
diplomatic immunity and they just,
it's scarred up my new specs.
Qatari Kikuyu, a Tiara,
whatever the fuck that is one of
those strange pregnant, probably not,
even if they hurt,
they don't even use the English language.
So like their letters are
different than our letters.
So we write something like really awful
like QT a r I or something like that.
It's our fuck up.
They don't even use are like,
why do we make it so you know?
Why does it have to be such a weird
fucking civilians? We got wrong.
Say it like what does it sound like?
Bitch was right it,
it's so hard. Tell me, tell
me what it sounds like.
You need some new letters?
We're fine.
We're just got to stop talking
to people that use phlegm.
I don't know.
He's not listening to me
sort of rant. That was back when people
were actually terms. A lot of things,
right? They had a lot of really
beautiful things with them.
They ate a lot of cheese.
It was a big part of the Diet.
There's a lot of phlegm in the air.
Back then people were Super Fleming.
It goes back to what we were
talking about before. Human Voice.
I could do some crazy shit.
You can do some crazy shit with this.
Have you seen there's a video of a girl
who can sing two pitches at the same
time. It's fucked up. What? Yeah, and
she can move them in opposite direction.
She can hold one, move another one.
Like she's just using her body.
I'll look it up. How is she? Well
Jamie will do it and pull it up.
Put Your headset on. There's
a word for it. He'll find it.
There's Tuvan throat singing in,
in Mongolia where they're
activating all of these overtones.
Literally singing courts like shit,
none of us do like tunnels,
phonic overtone
singing,
but more than one.
I'm trying guys do my best.
So do you think that this is something
that she was a born with this ability or
all? We can all do it. We could do
it. We all have the equipment.
It's like perfect pitch.
You know about what perfect pitches?
No. So it starts with pitches,
the ability to just recognize
frequencies as per the musical alphabet.
So if I went like this and B
flat, yeah, you would know,
oh that's a g because I know the sound
of that frequency and we are all born
with this, but for the most
part it's not really useful.
So we just kind of
phase it out. Right. Um,
but some people develop it or for some
weird kind of developmental reason,
they hold on to it. Um, and if you're
a musician, super can be super helpful.
But this chick, she's just doing what we
can all do, but she's just developed it.
Let's hear it.
Okay.
The lady and the cat.
Yes.
Just kind of a bad too.
Or
or,
oh,
[inaudible]
it goes on for minutes with, she'll just
eat control. She has this incredible,
oh my gosh. Has an English
accent. She was an obituary.
Not English in my mind is
perfect.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
So is this something that she developed?
Yeah.
Do you think can do it? Joe? I believe
in you. Believe in me. Interesting.
Isn't it? Beautiful support takes
us so far. Yeah. I just, that's,
that's insane. Yeah. Have you
heard Tuvan throat singing? No.
It's a Mongolian. Thanks. Super
Traditional. Here's the thing. No,
right now it's a novelty because that
doesn't sound as good as someone singing.
Awesome. So it was kind
of silly. If I can,
I can sort of agree that
was more like introductory.
That would be like you like being
like this is how you sweep the knee.
I don't really know the
terminology sweeped in Asia
our friendship is on a different level,
but at some point I really hope you
can teach me the martial arts ways.
Do you teach us can actually I was sure,
yeah. We'll show you guys some stuff.
I don't have the time to spend kind of
like really train you because he like lit.
No.
This is why I'm gonna say this because
if you really want to learn martial arts,
martial arts is not something that you're
ever going to get good by dabbling.
Sure.
You're going to have to get obsessed with
it and going to do it all the time and
I don't have the time to teach
you all others do what I'm saying.
What I would is,
what I would do is I would introduce
you guys to some movement and some nice,
great and I would show you what your
body's possible of if you understood where
to put it in like simple stuff.
There's like simple stuff that you can do,
especially Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is the like one of the easiest
ones for me to explain to someone because
then I can explain to you in a
way that I get my kids to do it.
Like my kids choke me all
the time trying to teach,
trying to teach my kids to them,
trying to teach my kids to
utilize their hips properly,
throw their weight and do a kick.
Like there's a snap your head.
Yeah. It's amazing. I really way it
totally is and I had a death. I didn't.
You give me the poem faith.
Well that isn't a way it's is it a way
in the same way that we were talking
about pool is is it in a way or we'll
call it when it's nice when it's nice,
when it's nice to look at like when
someone's dancing. It's nice to do that.
When I think about guitar,
that's a huge reason why I want to take
martial arts is because of how it would
impact playing the guitar,
playing an instrument,
doing anything because all
of a sudden your efficiency,
your movement changes and you're
capable of different stuff. Yeah.
I think everything is like that.
I think.
I think if you watch like a
little kid's gymnastics class, um,
I take my kids to gymnastics and I watched
his little kids bounce around and uh,
it's very interesting watching like
someone nail something, you know,
like there's these girls that are older,
probably like a 12 or 13 or something
along those lines. And they're like,
just starting to figure
out how to do back flips.
And they're just starting to
figure out how to land gracefully.
And then there's girls that
are even older than that,
like maybe 16 and 17 that are just wicked
and you're watching them flip through
the air and you're like cheesy as fuck.
And there's some young boys that do like
these crazy ring exercises where they
can stretch,
the arms are straight and they're fucking,
they bring their feet up above their
head and they flip over and they do a
handstand. I mean, it's nuts, right?
There's something about
watching someone nail movement,
you know, it's just like, it's
inspiring. It's just like guitar,
what someone's shredding.
It's someone doing a drum solo and
it impacts everything. So I play,
I loved playing jumps and I have, I've
put a lot when I was a kid, less now.
But I have basically a narrowed my
practice down to one thing, one thing.
And I feel pretty fine about it,
you know?
I feel like with that one kind of concept,
I can get where I want to go,
which is have any of my limbs do what
any of my other limbs can do. You know,
my left hand can do it.
My right foot has to be able to do it.
My left foot can do it, vice
versa. You know what I'm saying?
You have to be on heart. It has to
not make the that you want them. Nice.
And when I was doing that, I
started, I would notice myself,
I'll sudden I'd be eating with my
left hand. You know what I mean?
I wouldn't even think about it. I started
shooting basketballs and my left hand,
I didn't even know. But yeah,
dude, I was fucking, no,
I mean I've missed the shot horribly.
But you know,
I think of drums can be as a person who
doesn't know how to play any musical
instruments. I think of drums, sculpture.
This is what I think I sing. I think
when you're, when you're drumming,
like when I watch it,
like a heavy duty drum solo,
I think half of what this guy has to do
is get away from whatever restrictions
his body has on his movements.
Like half of what a drummer is doing,
it's so physical.
There's so much speed and coordination
involved that half of what you're doing
is heightening your ability to move in
like the exact way you want it to move to
create a certain sound. And a guy like
me, I can't do it. You know, if I,
if I brought them, I mean I
could eventually, I'm sure
learn how to play drums.
What I'm saying,
like if I brought someone into my world
and made them do something that I do
physically all the time,
like an odd thing, like play
pool or something like that.
If they didn't know how to play pool,
it'll be real awkward and goofy
and the body wouldn't move. Right?
But if they know,
they know where the fucking stick is gone,
I don't know how to do it.
Like I see this,
it's half of what he's doing is trying
to cut down on the amount of resistance
in his body,
listening to his mind
to make the sound. It's the same thing
with any instruments, violin or whatever.
It's just on a micro level. You know
what I mean? It's just more contained.
And that's why I think martial
arts, dude, once we do that,
we'll fucking take over the world.
Can you come on the road with us and
we'll give you John my hard to do,
but we could do more shows like
we're doing new year's eve.
[inaudible] bitch,
if you guys want to go to that.
There was not many tickets left.
I'll just tell you right now.
It's not even a October.
What is it?
September 28th or something today.
What is the 28th? Um, but it's,
it's a crazy show. It's a honey
honey. It's, um, Joey Diaz.
Duncan Trussell, Ari Shaffir and me at
the Wiltern in Los Angeles. New years ago,
2016 were ready. We were here for the
end of the world. That didn't happen.
I think maybe because of us.
Whoa show. I think the show with you
mean Stan hope and Diaz had been,
so you said this podcast and
things, the universe said, kill.
Let's give these dumb monkeys a
chance. Pulled together. Pretty Dope.
End of the Mayan calendar show, but
it was so fun and we said how, Hey,
we got to do more of those. We'd
fucking never dead. We'd never done it,
but we didn't for three years.
Three years from the last one.
It's been simmering that
Marriner was going to be writing.
You have no wine before it's time.
Remember watching wells still
stills commercials. I don't
remember that. Yeah. See,
you have to let her remember.
No women before the fight.
Rocky, the legs, the legs.
Oh yeah.
I saw that on Youtube in a movie theater
back when there was no newspapers back
when people were sending
messages on pigeons and shit.
They had smoke signals
if something was wrong.
That's when I saw it.
That's amazing.
Lots of change. What were you
saying that you saw on Youtube?
You were talking about something
that you'd seen on Youtube.
We'll watch Spalding gray, Spalding gray.
So yeah, I saw that guy on television,
actual television and I
think he like he did movies.
He did some short films
too and like great. Yeah,
I think he did like movies
of his storytelling, but
that's what they released.
Jonathon Dami shot this Cambodia
thing was the film. That's right.
So He's in the movie theaters in my mind,
for whatever reason it was on
HBO or something like that.
I guess that's not entirely correct.
I think it actually was a movie theater.
I'm trying to
pull the sound of the cubes,
the cubes, refill guys. I don't know. I
think I do a lot of time for round two.
We were talking about old people earlier
and it's interesting because bringing
it all back, alcohol, there's so many
things. Oh Joe, you never have to.
But as a bartender shirts
your bowels. It's the glass
break. She'd get new eyes,
he's got a solution. But that's
good. Thank you. So many lessons.
There are solutions out there.
I think about old people a lot.
When I get like you wake up and you
have a stiff neck and you're like you're
miserable and you're like crotchety
cause your neck hurts or your shoulder or
whatever from the van or whatever we're
doing on tour and then I'm like this
must be what it's like to be old.
No,
except like a hundred a hundred
times worth a hundred times worse.
Like you have ailments all day.
You might not have pooped for
four days and you need those.
My mind is the balance thing. That's
what my son, my dad has neuropathy.
Does that mean she's losing
the feeling in his feet?
Let's before we get into that,
is that the drink I was going to send him?
Oh No, no. He's going to
be going in. Okay. Yes.
I'm going to ease up on this like cocaine
for Ben and cocaine is like cocaine
for me.
Can I tell you guys something funny
while Ben Pours himself a drink,
you want to choose there's black
and drink crushing everybody.
Okay. All totally game.
Peer pressured but it's working.
I know you and that Gal travel together.
You gotta you gotta find a comfortable,
but who do you think's driving?
You're not kidding. Listen,
we have time please.
Plenty of places to eat around here.
It's great to be here. Yeah, please.
So recently back to my
dad's health problems.
People that are about to kick
off into the next dimension.
Did you hear about those fucking people
that they were on that ghost hunter show
a murder suicide.
The husband killed the wife and killed
himself apparently or allegedly in real
life and real life ghost hunting.
One of those ghost hunting reality
shows and there was like a standoff.
Apparently there had been
like some physical violence,
domestic violence issues,
mature
them before working partnerships.
And I think the girl was trying to,
the woman was trying to get
away from the guy allegedly,
I really shouldn't talk about
this cause my, my information,
amount of information I had about
the actual, the actual, you know,
physical case that the murder suicide,
it's very small but because I think
they're still investigating it. Right.
You know the story really, really, really
recently, a couple of days ago. Yeah.
Oh my God. Yeah. Terrifying. But I
mean how crazy is that these people,
you think about what a ghost
hunter is at the end of the day,
besides a bullshit artist,
it goes under the end of the day.
What it goes tenor is, is a
historian of tragedy. Wow.
Cause all,
you're always involved in some story
where there was a mass murderer.
I don't not believe in ghosts.
I don't believe in ghosts,
but I don't not believe in ghosts.
But what the idea would it goes
to is a ghost hunter is right.
If you're a person who's going to
a psych ward, okay. And you're,
you're waiting in the basement for ghosts,
you go into a place where people have been
murdered. Well yeah, yeah. But you're,
you're also constantly
concentrating on murder.
Constantly saying like for that and the
tension involved in the expectation of a
TV show. Dude, if I don't, you
know, if it's not entertaining,
we're going to lose her job. None of them
were entertaining. So that's no problem.
Non Entertaining shows.
Here's every ghost a hundred show that's
ever been night vision in the basement.
What was that sound? Did you hear
that? And he didn't cut to commercial.
That's ever speaks every one of them.
I don't know if we were speaking
about frequencies earlier,
but I think we were maybe the thing
you thing, but there's a theory.
This dude had that low frequency
sound like crazy low below 40 hertz,
which is just like the military
experimented with like to dog.
Sounds like with this is below that.
Yeah.
They were saying buildings that produce
this kind of a frequency and machinery
that does this.
There's a correlation between haunted
houses and these places because this kind
of frequency can induce hallucination
and people can induce really erratic
behavior. It's crazy. There's,
there's the,
what frequency did Hitler had readers
like the forfeiture Ontarian what is it?
Vegetarian. That was what
Hitler was, right? Vegetarian.
Sure. He was really, Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. He's also an artist.
Mommy issues. Poor guy. You feel
like if he got to them early in life,
you can prevent it a lot.
I think you met him like when
you guys were both 20 bro,
we would've saved the angel of death.
Like,
you know what I feel differently about
the things I was thinking about earlier.
Maybe what you're going to do now.
Oh good luck for Hitler.
Right? If you love that Song, love
that song. Hello. I love you guys.
Cool to be friends with someone that
you're friends with, fans of bizarre,
you know, bizarre. You know, it's just,
we thought about you a lot.
Mushier and Montana. We were,
we were in Montana for about two
weeks. Well, nationally. Yeah,
I know. We were, it was so
beautiful. But like, you know,
wilderness is everywhere and
everybody's like, you know,
if you go up here you got to like
be careful. Like we were in Wyoming,
we were in Yellowstone and you
know, we, we heard so many stories,
so many bear stories and things that like
really freaked me out because I mean,
I don't have anything to defend myself.
I would like to go into nature.
You've got your width girl.
Yeah. Well, you're right.
You're cautious about
nature for the most part.
The reality about animals for
the vast majority of instances,
the animals don't want to have
anything to do with people.
They want to get the fuck away
from you. Well, that's not true.
But when we were in Yellowstone, so I
heard all these stories about people like,
you know, people get killed by
grizzlies a few times a year,
and we were in Yellowstone and literally
a week later there was a hiker that got
nabbed by Grizzly bear. You know, it just
depends on, it's like just bad timing.
And I never ever want to put
myself in that position of that.
I got go camping here.
That's fine. You know,
I'll go camping in Joshua tree
timing in a way.
But it is also a lack of an understanding
of the environment for the most part,
with a lot of them.
Sure.
But although the one of the guys that got
killed recently was a very experienced
hiker, so man, I might
have to take that back.
You could fuck up and zig when you
should've zagged. And the biggest,
the biggest fear is running into a
mother, to a mother. Bear with her cubs.
Like, I can, I can appreciate
nature in a way that is, I,
it's so fucking beautiful. And like, yeah,
we drove through the park
and it was incredible and,
but like I don't feel like I
need to sleep there and, and,
and like I can walk along the river by
the car and I feel fine and I know I
might sound like a total
fucking charge right now, but,
but I really like what you thought of
being torn apart by an animal is utterly
terrifying.
Intelligent
approach. Okay. Yeah, it is a beautiful
thing. I think about being, I mean,
they feel better ironman and experiencing
kind of caution and fear too.
You're like, holy fuck, I'm a little
bit more connected now because yeah,
I do actually have to be wary of something
threatening to me as opposed to just
unload.
I swear when you're there,
that's not what you're thinking about
because the houses are so small and the
reality of the beauty of it all,
which is what the vast majority of the
experience is beautiful. The vast, vast,
vast, vast, vast majority. The, The Times
that I've encountered bears in the wild.
Claire's don't want to have
nothing to do with people.
They want to get the groceries
and stuff. No, I have not.
Some grizzlies stuff I'm talking about,
those are the ones who you have to worry,
but you just gotta be prepared. If
you bring guns, you know, you'll,
you'll always have to be repaired.
And you,
we tried to shoot a grizzly
and it'll still easy,
but there's also a lot of noisy
with the right kind of gun.
You have to have more than
one person and you have to be,
you have to be ready in case at Hammons.
But most of the time you don't shoot them.
They shoot at the ground and you scare
them off and they're like, fuck this.
And they just get out of
there and then they go about,
you can enter into the natural on in most
situations and get out without having
to do anything where something
dies where it didn't have to die.
But there are occasions where
like I knew a guy who, uh,
went hunting in Alaska and uh,
they got charged by Grizzly bear and
wound up having to kill the grizzly bear.
The grizzly bear tried to get it there,
kill it was a,
it was actually a mother and they would,
you know,
they just didn't want to
have anything to do with her,
but she just decided she was going to
make a rush at them. And I've seen it,
I've seen it on video too.
I've seen people, yeah,
you're going out to kill
something in the wilderness.
You got to pick where you go. Honestly,
that's what I'm talking about.
Super Dangerous to go where grizzlies are.
That's exactly what I'm talking about.
The most scary places. Sure. National
Park, they used to have that show on, um,
I think, I don't want to, was discovery
channel, whatever it was called,
called the hunt, who was the one
where the guy from Metallica,
James Hetfield from Metallica
is apparently a big time
hunter. And he hunted, uh,
like he's a hundred all
over the world and he's a,
or at least a bunch of different species,
all these photos of him. And He, uh,
hosted this show where they
were hunting for grizzly bears.
It was like a really controversial show
cause you don't really eat grizzly bears.
I mean you can, but they do
not, they're not endangered,
but they're not doing great. You know,
they're not like sort of flourishing.
They know how many they should kill
and they know how many they can kill.
They like date,
they have like this estimation that
wildlife biologists puppy off man,
take his pants up, fried Ben,
he's taking his pants off.
Risley's you're still here. But for the
most part, they don't fuck with people.
For the most part. They don't
want have anything to do with you.
For the most part, they'd rather get
away. They don't want to get shot.
They just want to stay away from people.
Well, so when we were up there, you know,
you were like hanging with
the locals and of course,
like I'm up from those areas.
So I have all these questions about what's
it like out there in nature. You know,
you live in, in Montana and you know, we,
we met this guy who was just in,
maybe he was being dramatic,
but he was telling me all these
horrifying stories where I'm like,
why would anyone want to put
themselves in that position?
And I think it's a matter of,
like you said, being fully
aware of the environment,
having that, that preparation, you know,
stories people tell honestly,
like you're in that area.
And then there's like a whole culture
bear fear and things like that.
Um, and at least in certain areas, but
it's just like, that's what we talk about.
We talk about how this
one guy who got killed in
Yellowstone, but it's like, it's,
I don't think it's the kind of threat,
I don't know why I'm reacting
so strongly to it right now,
but I feel like it's not the kind of
threat that you smoke the cocaine,
not the threat right now, right here.
Yeah. Know when you living in Los Angeles,
the hunger is a bear is not the threat,
but you're smart to be aware that it is.
It's on the table if you're out.
Yeah.
Well Joe, I love nature. I love to fish.
Fishing is one of my greatest passions
when I have the time to do it.
I fucking love it. I'm learning
how to fly fish. It's really fun.
And I have all these goals of
these places I want to go to.
They're places that scare me.
Like I don't,
I don't want to be fishing fly fishing
for salmon and there's a grizzly bear
across the river. Like that kind of thing
is like, and that's fine. I respect that.
I will stick with the area that I feel
safe and because I don't have a rifle on
me, I don't have Joe Rogan with his,
his, you know, acute target practice,
you know what I mean?
So I think about this a lot because,
well, you wouldn't want me, first of all,
you'd want someone who would be
teaching me. It'd be fun, whatever.
Like some of my friends that have been
lucky to be friends with the take me to
the woods, like Cameron Hanes or a Steve
Or, no, the guy who was that. Oh awesome.
That's great.
I like that.
Then that's like that's the best way
you want to go fishing with me and just
talks about that a bunch of times like
we should do shows were take people for
the first time that had never been
hunting because it's such a bizarre
experience.
Even if you don't shoot anything,
just being in the woods in
Montana makes you go, oh my God.
Like it makes you realize
like, wow, life is very,
it's very different than
what we've accepted.
We've accepted that life is
cities and life is, you know,
whole foods and life is,
well, here's the thing, Nate.
Sure.
If you want to talk about it,
like going out to nature and nature
is everywhere. Like we live in a city,
but nature is, is everywhere. It's in
the fucking middle of your sidewalk.
You know, there are bird, there
are crows, there are hawks.
I mean there's just so many. Like it's
everywhere. We live in the middle of it.
Coyotes,
mountain lions.
We also,
it's like we don't see nature a lot.
So I think sometimes we look at nature
like an old girlfriend that we haven't
called it a long time.
We only have this like really elevated
idea of who she was and then you get back
with her and you realize this
pitch doesn't give a fuck about me.
It's like that because when you're on
the top of a mountain and there's no cell
phone service and there's animals
creeping around and you're like,
this is a fucking dangerous
place to be standing still. Yeah.
It doesn't care about you. Can I
give a fuck? Yeah, it's beautiful.
But I think
that you're, that girlfriend is
here though. Like I think there's a,
this sad misconception with the way that
people treat quote unquote nature when
they drive out to a national park as
opposed to when they treat their urban
setting,
which is there is nature here and,
but people don't think about the fact
that they throw their trash out the window
and there's ducks in the pond right next.
You know all this stuff,
like you're still in nature.
Even if you're in a city,
you just need to treat it that way.
Well, the idea that, you know, look
at the city is not being natural.
Spectrally sitting, not being
natural itself. Of course,
it's all the bizarre,
the throwing of litter on the ground,
like when people want and really open
up their window and throw their garbage
out the window on the
highway. You're like, what?
That I just throw a bag and then
whenever we see that on the road,
I just want to fucking punch
him square in the throat.
It's so bizarre how many people do it.
Well,
they'll open up a window and throw a bag
out. Didn't happen. And you're like, what?
Yeah, you just throw our garbage.
A Wendy's bag. Yeah. Yeah.
Like people are stupid or just like
a little piece of paper, you know,
like, like some fucking top of
something. You know over the gum.
You spit your gum out. The window
is really bad. Birds eat gum,
they think it's like a, a piece of
food and then they die. Fuck birds.
Listen John,
the way out
there, there's so many fucking birds
and this is why it's really important.
If we get to talk to me, you can't take
me seriously ever. It's super important.
Cats,
cats and you were like, cats are awful
because they have the thing in there.
They have the parasite.
Why didn't say it that way?
And then you have the cheese
cats in the world them so much.
They're sweeties.
That's a cute cat cat's
term called making muffins.
You know when they need,
they're so fucking you
like that too needy.
Yeah, I would say it's more like
pizza dough. Okay. That works.
They were worried when he called pizza
dough, just looking for the reaction.
Joey d is how the best bit about that.
About doing coke with his cat.
And this cat was doing that Paul
thing. It's hilarious. Betty,
you should do about doing coke with his
cat. What? I'm looking at one window.
He's looking at the other one.
Oh,
so freaking out a lot of the time,
like I think I kind of see that and we
know what they're their nature's cleanup
crew man. And the only reason you're
alive because you're way bigger than them.
That's it. If you're smaller than a cat,
it would fucking eat you. You can't have,
you could have a dog and a pet durable
and you could teach that dog to not fuck
that durable up. You could teach
that jog. Hey Dude, listen to me man.
The Jermel off the menu and
the dog. Got It. Got It.
Don't kill the [inaudible] really badly.
You know.
How do you think dogs are with cats?
Like if dogs grow up with cats,
they're totally cool with that.
If they don't grow up with cats,
they're fucking dangerous as shit around
the kill cats all the time. Right?
So they make these pretty insane cats.
Cats won't make
a pet rat and the cat in the house leave.
Watch what happens.
It's going to be like
Joe and you did the test with your cats.
I want to know.
I've never had a pet rat.
I do know that cats other than
like a few breeds of what?
Click Super Fluffy Persians that get
to that weird non aggressive state.
They're just these weird, they're
just branching cuddle. Yeah,
the genetic aberrations.
That's her fucking predators.
The predators.
It's amazing.
Plus then you see these videos of like
huge African lions in like these reserved
areas of of Africa snuggling with the guys
that worked there on Youtube.
It can happen in the lion damn fed well
and they're taken care of well and their
raise,
well,
it's very obvious that there's some guys
that know how to make a friendship with
a lion.
You're starting to look,
but it's not that much different
than the idea of a wild dog.
Like there was a few instances,
like I think there was one where
a couple was killed in Georgia.
I want to say it was like a
couple of years ago by wild dogs.
There's a pack of wild dogs to kill
these people cause people would let their
dogs loose and the dog's just never came
home. Or maybe they didn't feed him or,
and they became feral or
they were raised outside.
I read about cutting out a woman
in Canada singer. Yeah. Yes.
She told us about that. Joe
Did. She was killed about that.
Joe
told you,
but we stayed at a winery on
Saturday night, actually Joe,
it was a really sweet Rogan Fan.
This, this fellow that was like,
you guys need a place to stay after the
show. And of course we do. You know,
you gotta save money.
Photos of you guys in naked online now.
They probably were sleeping. We
have never been naked. Everyone.
We're never nudes. That's never needs.
If you just operate like that, I
don't talk. And you never say the wrong
shit. Trust me. It's the way to go
play it safe guys talking,
always dressed. But we were,
we all slept in this fucking RV
and it was awesome. But they were,
they were like coyotes and it was great.
It was amazing. But you can hear it.
They were right outside. It was so
loud and they had this incredible like,
you know, it's, it's funny, but I thought,
I honestly makes feel
good about that story.
But that singer that you told us about,
about the girl that was hiking,
we've got to pack on the road.
We've got to pack.
They're not going to fuck
with us. I would, I would
tackle coyotes for you, Ben.
You wouldn't even have,
I carry a Taser on me most times you
left it in the car like in a really weird
exposed place that it was one time
days or laying on the fucking seat.
Almost zap myself. You have to
turn it on properly so you're fine.
Maybe you left it on. I Dunno, I didn't.
You can't be alone with, yeah, that's it.
You can be alone on the
same team, but she's talking
about the Taser thing. Sorry.
Yeah. If you're alone, they're going
to say, okay, there's a weakness here.
We can exploit it.
We're going to fucking dude.
And the girl apparently was really small.
She was like less than a hundred pounds
and they were like, we could do this.
You can just fucking do it. And
they did. They did killed her.
We watch a lot of planet earth in the,
in the car and our travels and you know,
there's
no,
it's tough.
Do you think that the way that you think
about that stuff has changed that you
have kids? It's like, oh fuck.
It's just accelerated. But
it was always there. Oh. So
there was always bizarre
to me how dangerous
natural world is and how it's right now,
dangerously we fuck with it. You know,
like we manipulate shit. Like I
said, I'm from Ohio and there was,
this is fucked up. Check
this shit out. Okay.
And the Cleveland Metro Parks
where I'm from and where I, my,
my family resides, there's obviously a
deer population that's out of control,
like a lot of places and people get
sick of hitting them with their cars.
So they thought it was a good idea to
bring coyotes in to deplete the deer
population, which they're not
native to that area. So there,
there's coyotes in Ohio now, which is
so fucking weird. It's not natural.
And like, you know, people start losing
their dog and they, they had like,
they don't think about those things.
And I remember hearing a story of a, of,
I don't know, I couldn't
tell you, but who the, um,
a good family friend of ours
was telling the story that, uh,
her young children were playing in
the backyard as they always did.
And she looked outside the window and
she said there are two coyotes in there
treeline.
She ran outside and they're like,
her little kids were just playing there,
but people aren't used to that. You know?
It's not like you have Montana and you
know that there's bears there and you
know that there's wolves.
It's like this new introduction of,
of people manipulating with nature
and it's not not cool man. Okay,
well there was a lot of times people are
trying to right wrongs like that's what
they're trying to do with
the wolf population trying
to right the wrongs because
they did poison wolves.
They used to be more wolves.
I'm not exactly sure if you,
if you really want to be safe and
you really want to have a city and
civilization, I don't think you
want a large population of wolves.
I think it's probably super important
if you want to keep this whole people
thing going on at the level of going on
now where we can get new Samsung phones
every six months.
These fucking wolves around like this
shit is the whole reason why we invented
cities in the first place and the city
people forgot. Did you ever see that,
that video about how wolves
changed the Yellowstone park?
The the rivers? Yeah. Like
they do serve a purpose.
Yeah, but the purpose is an odd one.
The purpose is that of a Predator,
like it's like this
idea that the only one,
that one thermal balance
but not necessarily because
you don't want lions in La.
Okay. You just don't, but there are but
there's not ones but no, but they're,
they're cougars. They're smaller. There's
more scared put six but a large line,
like a 600 pound line.
Like what if a few of them started
living in La and we're like, hey,
we have to do with it man.
You know what of the eat skateboarders
w we would have to like accept that.
That's fine. You can eat
the skateboarders. They're
a natural part of nature.
They have to,
they actually eat too.
We've been fucked that we would kill
those lions. Okay. We would kill them all.
Weed if they, if the line eight your
friend. Okay. If you came home one day,
mine was eating Ben,
what kind of an attitude you think
you'd have towards that line?
He'd be very upset with him.
Can we,
can we get a little more detail
on the scenario because, well,
this is what happened,
but you know,
we're just a flesh wound
president that decided to,
the only way for us to
have total compassion is to
open up the borders to all
plants and animals.
I'm just trying to fill a barrel with
a proud extreme coyotes everywhere.
You look killing kids.
Too many kids. Fuck it.
We have to be a part of the solution.
I think there's a lot in predators.
Take out people up to date.
Are you on Terminator?
We should end this podcast right now.
That would be a perfect way to end it.
I'm not at all. I've
missed the boat. Come on.
We can fill you in on one and three if
you're interested. This is a new one.
Which one is the new? Is it just blue
ray? I didn't want one. Just came out.
Sign out yet.
I live in a small five of them from game
of Thrones and said Khaleesi oh wow.
They're really pretty girl. The
mother of dragons. Wow. Powerful.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not on
speaking terms with the terminator,
but the problem is
I could go back and watch those movies.
There's a lot of movies I need to watch.
But what would really bothers me about
the terminator movie in particular is
that we might have like real
terminators talking about dude,
that that's why I wanted to bring up the
top 50 years might be a real problem.
People are talking about it.
Talking about Musk, Bill Gates,
did you hear about that? Stephen Hawking,
they signed this letter to be like,
we cannot have AI, but it's weird
because they signed this letter.
We can't have autonomous,
uh, weaponry. Oh Jeez.
And then, uh, but they're also,
at least the Elon Musk is,
but a bunch of these
guys are investing in Ai.
So it's like drawing that line because
they probably want to be ahead of it.
But first of all, yeah, and if you
are, if you're in the tech business,
hedging their bets. But if you're in
the business, like if you look at,
I mean I'm just assuming
that if you're a tech guy,
like a part of what it is is about
innovation at its highest form.
Like what's innovation at its highest
form other than artificial intelligence.
It's like the highest form of innovation.
Sure.
The creating of a life of some sort of
sentient being out of plastic and metal,
three d printing.
Like what's the same discussion as the
three d printing stuff with this dude,
Cody Wilson came out and was like,
I'm going to print guns because,
because it's someone's going to, yeah.
You know what I mean? And then like,
so you look at it and you say,
well,
it's something that we can't change if
it's something we can't change and what
does it to put our bunker? Oh God. Anyway,
were tiring. Joe Joe's tells
you and just some terrified.
It's scary and maybe all I was so scared.
No something. I'm tired of hearing
about it. I said scared. No,
it's good of the society.
We,
we hang on a string all the time and it
just, we keep, keep fixing that string.
We're really good at keeping
the string going. Well,
we assumed that the string has to stay
and we know that that's not really true
and that's why we love movies about
where the string breaks and the Mad Max.
La Shit got crazy.
Where's the water park?
I know there's no law. There's no role.
You have to fight to the death. I mean we,
it's Barstow. You know, it's the
worst. If you go to Barstow right now,
it's fenced in in for 10 years
it would be thunder dome. Yeah.
I mean there's, there's swats
we can manipulate and take off,
cut them off to the rest of the
world and they would be like that.
And there's places that are like that. Now
we keep saying that and like, you know,
go to Africa, we've got to go to
Africa. John, but you went to Africa.
I go this parts of Africa that
probably crazier. Exactly this,
there's a great vice piece
on his place in Monrovia,
in Liberia where it's just like,
it's a total wasteland.
People are shitting in the street,
the governor or at some high political
official came down at shout on the beach
just to be like, I'm one of
the people. And you know,
like this is how we're doing it.
That's what he did. Yeah, it's crazy.
It votes was that before Ebola broke out
because it was like people that that
was part of the like I didn't cause the
phone. Well yeah, it's, it's, it's all
the unsanitary conditions and stuff.
People living in filth. That's part of
it. I don't know. But, but you know,
can I, I really feel fucking
really strongly about this.
Do we to talk just don't
really feel strongly about,
you know,
we're talking about like hanging by a
string and stuff like that and you know,
all God, the government sucks and all
this stuff and it's all, this is true.
There's, there's, you know,
you could click a button and
just kill a lot of people,
but at the end of the
day, while we're here, um,
there's some really beautiful things to
experience, like your shows, comedy shows,
and you make people feel good. And what
about, why is the beautiful, I look,
I'm talking, going down the list here.
Let me have my moment. And you know,
there's all these incredible
things and you know,
some something that we
get to see on the road.
Like we'll have like our scheduled honey
honey shows where you buy your tickets
and then occasionally we'll have these
really cool opportunities to play like um,
a concert series that like small towns
will have where they're not the most,
they have no idea who we are,
which is awesome because we'll go,
we went to this town and Dylan Colorado
where literally like I would say maybe
10% of the people were there to see us,
but the rest of the people were there
cause they lived in the town and they
wanted to have their
entertainment for the night.
And so there was all
these different people.
They were like really young families and
really old people and they all brought
their lawn chairs and beers and we were
in this outdoor amphitheater on this
lake and there's, you know, I don't
know, like five or 600 people there,
something like that.
And end it like it was such
a cool experience because
there was this collective
experience of all these people that came
together for whatever they needed at
the time that wasn't like, you know, it,
it wasn't about us. We were offering
what we could to the situation,
but at the end of the day it was really
beautiful because it was all these
people that were having this
experience together in their own way.
And it was different races,
demographics and,
and like it was just, we had this
moment and it was, it was really cool.
And I think right now when the world is
in this really funny place that's really
scary and we can put energy into
how scary it is and all that stuff,
but we can also put energy into these,
um,
experiences together where we're trying
to figure it out, you know, and like that.
I think that's really important.
Yeah.
I think most of what people are fighting
over has nothing to do with most of the
people. Yeah. You know, most
of the people in the world,
the, the, what do we want to do? We want
to just hang out with their friends,
go to dinner. Yeah. We don't
want to take over the oil fields.
Most of the people just want to have
a good time. Most of the people,
there are a few people who like really
want to push that whole making money
envelope to the point where
we want to invade countries.
That's 90% of what's wrong
with us is it's not most of us,
most of us.
And I think this is what we're able to
do now that we weren't able to do before.
As most of us can talk to each
other, we can, you know, like you,
you can get whatever you message out,
whatever your messages out in a way that
you've never been able to do before.
So if you want to do it in a song, do
you want to do it with an ebook? You can,
you can get your message out in this room.
Don't tell anybody. It's a tolerance,
a rap song that we love you
Brownie points if you're white.
Right.
But I think,
I mean this is the best time ever.
Like people that's, Oh, the world is
falling apart. No, I don't damn it.
I think it's always been fuck because
it's filled with people like the world's
always been fucked and win back.
Guess what?
People are fucked and we're
the best things on earth. Okay?
Turtles, goose island
with it is dark turtles.
You'd want to fucking kill yourself.
It's about a week.
If there was a million
living beings on the side,
the turtles one with these
beings, noon with them, please,
you shoot yourself right in the day.
If I gave you till two bullets,
one of them was for the turtle that you
were going to kill to stay alive for the
first day and the second one, are you
going to put right in your fucking mouth?
Damn. You're like, I'm not living
with turtles for the rest of my life,
not doing it. How do you put the
turtle too is do you have Saracha?
You just boil it. Just have to
bang rocks together. The light up.
Dry leaves. You got to get this.
You don't have to cook it just
to make sure you kill the parasites.
It tastes terrible. Thank God.
That's a pretty awesome thing. That
food tastes so good. If you, you know,
you're talking about the context
of things, how the world's changed.
She didn't taste this good. Oh
it's too good. A lot of the time.
Can we get art form now?
There's some art forms that are probably
been around for a long time with food,
right? Like cause a lot of
dishes, like there's some,
I mean we ethnic dishes.
I started to do some work with farm aid,
which has been really cool
and learned a lot about,
you know the whole fucking
structure of you know,
corporate food corporate literally like
all the hormonal shit and you know,
you, you're fine. I mean you've got your
like Moose and bear in your freezer.
Like your, your meat section is
covered. Thank God you guys enjoyed it.
It's okay. But, but you know,
they're the majority of the food that
people eat in, in their grocery stores.
You go to Safeway or you go
to fucking Piggly wiggly.
That shit is toxic and shit is awful.
It is God fucking awful.
I don't pin it will give you cancer.
I don't think it's the show,
honestly. Here's the thing about me,
like it's just how often
do you need and water.
If you ate that every day your she
would be fucked up. You'd be like,
why do I have acne? All of a sudden
you and free down not convince.
I don't know because this is the
only reason why I'm saying this.
What does a shitty protein? Well it's, I
don't know what it is or it isn't. See,
I don't understand. I see that. I just
want to be honest about it. I don't know.
Like what you actually get
off of a piece of meat.
It seems to me like logically I
am attracted to like a darker,
richer meat cause I feel like it'd
be a healthier animal more logically
essentially too. There's something
biologically doing like no, this is bad.
But then that's why it's counterintuitive
because like a lot of their like
really fatty cuts of meat are the ones
that people enjoy the most. You're right.
That's why they liked that. Why'd you,
why'd you hire say it, I don't know.
Japanese version of a beef with you
talking about fatty versions of meat that
have been processed to be
the appeal?
Like why would there,
I guess it was because like fats,
fats have always been super
important because people,
well it was hard to get food and they help
you digest too. They do a lot of shit,
but it also like you really wanted like
the attraction to things that have a lot
of calories.
That was one of the most important things
where people were starving to death
all the time.
I have to get that fat,
like fat was important and big was like
keep it because like we gotta be big,
but now you know, it's just, just
shows you how these things change.
Now bigger is kind of fucking
is over. Well, you know,
it's like over consumption,
but people are just so big now too.
Like there was a thing on TV the other
day about a kid who was in a senior in
high school. He's the biggest
football player ever. Whoa.
And he's a senior in high school.
Like he's seven feet tall,
440 pounds holy. And he's 17
years old. She's incredible.
It's insane. Like what? We're going
to go right to the fucking moon.
We're going to scrape the
moon with our heads that we're going to
just keep getting bigger. That's the big,
that's the function.
People,
they're gonna gonna run out of oxygen
and start dying because they're going to
pass through. They're going to get to a
point a thousand years from now, we're,
we're thousand.
We'll keep them out more about that.
That kid's diet and like what kind of
supplements he's taking and stuff like
that.
What did he eat if it was some crazy
lightning strike of like natural
phenomenon, that would be incredible
and I'm, I'm totally open to that,
but there's so many things like,
you know, like with processed meats,
like girls are getting their
periods at 11 today though. Yeah,
I mean that shit be fucking guys
standing there with a clipboard.
Have you started to bleed yet?
Keep Margaret.
Who is this?
God is asking these fucking period
questions. Be a guy. Better be a woman.
I hope you have a woman doctor that's
not a fucking creek. I hope it's not.
Some creepy the first time arrested today?
No,
he got sentenced to, this
is, this is terrible story.
This guy got sentenced to only one year
of house arrest and he pleaded guilty to
fucking eight of his patients
while they were under whole man.
He only got a year of house arrest.
That's horrifying.
People feel thought he
was going to get 20 years.
They tell you his name and social
security. You'll Google it, find him.
It's awful. Oh, oh. I was
getting, it's a twisted dude.
Talk about an inappropriate story,
but I'm Oh too late.
First Time
I had like a gynecology thing,
hollow like I was like 18 and it was a
male doctor and he was so hot that I like
did not know what to do with
myself. I remember being like, wow,
so while it's a scene in a porn,
it really was incredible.
I had my pelvis zapped with an electric
needle by a beautiful dermatologist.
God look at it and give you the thumbs up.
That's when it would have been really
weird about what the guy wasn't. I can't,
I wasn't there. I can't accept
while you are still in the building.
She's going to go to the restroom.
She might not want to talk about that.
Trying to get out of it. She had to
hold her to the fire. That's true.
It's a vagina thing.
That's considered for girls
talking to a story about a vagina.
You have to either comes or it doesn't
come. You can't like go. Come on,
tell it to us
and they will love that.
I think she'll love it. They
get mad. What happened? Come on.
Well this is kind of weird though.
What's up with your Dick? What's up?
So you were having a big problem.
That's the deal.
The Dick or the Dick
problems at pedals game.
What kind of did problem talking about
here? Phelan had a bandaid on my dick.
Once vaginas are infinitely
more sensitive to criticism.
You know like you can make a joke
about a dude having a stinky Dick.
But if you make a joke on stage about
a woman's mallow tourist vagina,
sure you will be a terrible person.
Did they want to have
anything to do with you?
Even if you're telling a true story.
If you did tell us true story
about a woman stinky vagina,
you would have to like really
word it. Well, you feel
like it's a double standard.
Yes, I do, but it's got to start
doing it. You got to lead the charge.
This is my thing.
I don't think necessarily that all
double standard double standards, uh,
are there because of inequality.
I think some double standards are there
because we want to quantify things
instead of just looking at them as being
completely different. Sure. He tell it,
dude is a cat. Dick Stinks and
it goes, all right, I'll wash it.
But also wildlife,
it's really gotta be serious if
you're up close to it and yeah,
it might be stinky as fuck.
It's very possible. If
you don't clean your Dick, it's very
possible you dick could be stinky. Sure.
The differences,
penises,
stinky decks versus Stinky vaginas
that a man saying a woman's vagina,
his stinky is like a terrible thing to do.
It's like it's a,
there is a double standard because
it is different. It's, it's,
it's a more powerful statement.
Yes.
Because if you tell a dude that is
dicks thinks, he goes, all right,
I don't wash my dick. Like that's it.
And you know once you wash your Dick,
it's clean. It's not going to continue
to, I'm doing freak out about it.
They'd be like, well what do you mean
what's my only, those guys are paid.
Most cats are just going to
watch their decade woman.
You're dealing with an
internal flora issue,
right? That's true. That's the issue of
having any sort of a yeast infection.
It's actually like you,
it's lifeforms living in your cooter.
That's way more sense.
Team size
affects the smell of your ges showed in
thinking about that for the last hour.
Well, we know it affects the smell of
your pee. Right? If you eat asparagus,
you can smell your asparagus
while you're peeing.
I got to assume that makes it into
your, your calm as well. Yeah.
The only makes sense.
I think lighter.
You brought up the gynecologists
locking eyes with each other. Just we
went right to the toilet. Felt that too.
We want to write into the toilet and
started talking about stinky dicks.
Not the direction I liked for
us to lead. It is what it is.
It is what it is. Live with
it. It's a funny thing.
But do you think that that's
why it's funny. It's like it's,
it's Ruder for some
whatever biological reason.
It's a router for man to mock a woman's
stinky vagina in a cruel fashion.
Do you think that security,
I think that's like a degrading
thing that you want to like, um,
just sort of a d value.
A woman's may be national place,
very possibly,
but it's also equally
negative on the other side.
When a woman mocks a man
for having a tiny Dick, Ooh,
not the size of the dots.
Like I swear by that lies, but
if a guy has a microchip for guys,
a little tiny deck,
like there's these guys that have
like micro objects like that.
And if it's like full on,
showed a tiny one,
like a little one, I'm saying like, oh
terror. Terrifyingly small little there.
And if someone mocks that, he's
really funny. Well that'll help.
But it's less offensive to make fun of
a stinky pussy than it is to make fun of
that because I think a stinky pussy
you can clean up. That's fine.
That's fine. All you need is some as
a dolphin. Listen, your life girl,
some wild Kimchi.
Need some raw foods.
Take care of your flora and my mom
and dad never listened to this.
Molly will, they've been
listening. You know what's up?
These chairs are fucking
dope, dude. They're not bad.
They're very good. Ergo depot,
shout out to Earl depot.
They sent him to us.
I was skeptical at first because I
had one before that was like super
uncomfortable. It was like one of those
knee ones where you go on your knees,
you know what I'm talking about.
You're in your, on your buttons,
some sort of a weird way and you're
going to tough to get used to,
but they do make you keep good posture
and then I got this other one that was
like a saddle within this dude from
Ergo depot hollered at me all he said,
those are not good for long term.
It's like you're sitting at a
desk for a long period of time.
You need something like this.
And he sent it to me and I was like,
but it looks like a regular chair. And
then you sit in it and you go, Oh shit.
It's called a cup pisco. That's what's
called you sit it and you go, Oh yeah,
I've perfect fucking posture.
All of these studies on your posture,
your posture
grenades,
people are watching you
and listening. Um, but,
but like the way your
body language expresses,
like there's certain
chemicals don't get crazy.
There were studies like this,
you know,
there's this like power stance that's
the Dick forward showing it's called the
Dick for no when guys are all,
so I go,
I put my feet up on the desk and I go,
Dick Forward.
You kind of know like guitar to
sound like a mood that's like a dick.
It's like a horse stance.
Oh, that's, is that true?
Why did I not know that
he's being serious? She was
serious. Yeah, I'm serious.
It's serious now. So Tig, dig,
dig straight down the river bend.
Let me have this dream.
Why don't we all just fucking sit back.
But if you sound like board,
especially if a guy has like maybe some
sort of an alligator skin cowboy boots
on and he puts his feet down on the
ground in some sort of an office chair,
you know what I'm saying? Some sort of
a risky environment. Yeah. And then, uh,
puts his hands behind his head,
leans back and goes, well,
how much do you like this job?
Not May know Tom about to go dig for,
hold on Y'all goals released
from that physical position.
Like you're fucking like,
Shit's going on for you.
Like you're getting more powerful by
sitting like that. Like Thor's hammer,
like Thor,
they say that about smiles right there.
Like when you smile, it actually, it
actually has an effect on your brain,
gives you a certain amount of happiness.
Now my problem with that,
I think mean it's positive. It's great.
Let's not sell our souls. So short. Yeah.
Fake it till you mean it. Hello? Oh Shit.
That's so beautiful to sing a song
we went to eat. You wouldn't beat,
wasn't even that good. Other
than that? No. Definitely not.
People at home,
we're, I need this. Your paths
have no emotions. Pretend you
do grow. They'll grow water.
Then with the tears of others.
Here's honey, honey. What?
They're fucking new hair.
That was delicious. Yeah.
This is a slam poem.
It's even worse than a regular problem.
Have you ever been to say it
in a voice that's not mine?
Always here and always on time.
Top of the mountain.
Bottom of the gully.
I been here before.
My friend Sally Jeanette
didn't have to ride
strong immigrant background
with a very good work ethic.
You got to make some shit, Ryan, if
you want to call it a poem. All right.
You can't just say a bunch of shit.
The lightning hits the thunder.
I'm on the street.
Why is he
doesn't love me as much
as he loves his new wife.
As I get in my car and I
wish my tire wasn't flat,
but it is deal with it.
I can't
tell on me. My alarm wakes up. I
wish my life was that interesting.
Back to the grind
and then I light my cigarette
and everybody just captured that.
You captured it.
You let your cigarette in this one
single tear and everyone was like,
everyone has a bone in your acting
days. I cry like a bitch, man.
Oh, fucking cry. People
get mad at me because
I cried so easy. But I just get it. I
don't cry for sad things. It's a weird,
I'm a weird person in that
way for like powerful thing.
That's fucking sad things. Sad
things make me really sad. But um,
I mean I can absolutely cry from them,
but a lot of times like involuntary
tears come from a really happy things.
It does is a useful, I
kind of was like, uh,
like I'll be talking
to somebody on the POC,
like Rhonda Rousey when she was in here.
I love talking to her about her,
her dad and her dad committed suicide
man and this chick that she was fighting
in her last fight. Oh, I saw it said
something that she interpreted as like,
she might kill herself like her father.
And you know whether or not that
was exactly what that girl man,
it didn't matter cause that's what
Ronda saw and that's what she,
and then she went out there and beat
the shit out that girl. And I was like,
no fucking crazy. But it
was, it was so, uh, it was,
it was, it was so crazy. It was
like this weird moment in history.
There was like this w like I have this
feeling for a minute that I was in this
place that there's going to
be a come a point in time.
It didn't matter if the girl
wasn't the right opponent for her.
Like w it didn't matter where the
girl was like a in her league,
what it was was what had happened in
this country with his chick had come
overseas, just beat the fuck
out of this girl on paper view.
I know it's a girl and then like,
so you have this crazy sport that
everybody resists. Like, oh my God,
it's barbaric. It's masculinity.
It's most toxic load.
The biggest star is a hot chick.
The base star,
the biggest stars sweat this.
The biggest star in the craziest,
most violent sport the world has ever
known is a beautiful woman who's highly
skilled,
who is a living Charlie's angels movie
who flies to other continents to beat the
fuck out of it. Just exactly
about a girl job. But girl, who,
if she decided to starve herself,
she could easily be a model. Right?
She's beautiful. Instead she
chooses to get an a metal tube,
a flight of South America. It'd beat the
fuck out of some chick on paper view.
And when you're there and you watch that
happen and you watched this paradigm
shifting moment, like for me,
I was like, Whoa, did you cry?
I almost did.
Then I almost did when I was interviewing
her and the tier leaked out a little
bit when I had her on the show
and I talked about it. Yeah.
But I almost cried when I was
talking to Connor Mcgregor.
I was talking to Connor Mcgregor
after he beat Chad Mendez.
When I was talking to, I was talking about
Ireland, Irish people in the audience.
Then in
in, in Vancouver. You guys were in
Vancouver while was happening? Uh,
he fought, the guy was from
Chad Mendez from California
will. Yes. We, we literally,
Joe,
we watched that show from a sports bar.
We didn't know who was coming to our
show in Vancouver. And I said to Ben,
I was like, I'll bet a bunch of people
from this bar are coming to our show.
And it was weird because it wasn't a
market that we're really, um, you know,
it's prevalent in,
and I'm not even joking you,
like 95% of the people that
were at that show were rogue
Rogan fans and they ha they were watching
that fight. So it was weird. Like I,
I,
you'd be amazed at how many parallels are,
we all have these
prejudices against people.
Like people that would be into
like MMA wouldn't be in the yolk,
your kind of music, but you're totally
wrong. We're all totally wrong.
We're all scared. We're
all like, you know,
we were talking about earlier
about like the natural world,
we're all like terrified of all
the dangers of like, you know,
when people didn't have the internet
and they didn't know who the people were
that were coming in boats,
we have less and less to fear.
We're more and more like each other.
And were we realized that more
and more on a daily basis.
So like when the mergings of our sort of
fans is like perfect example that like
universally the people that I introduced
to you, I don't want to play guys up,
but universally they love you. I mean,
you guys are awesome. It's not like I go,
hey, these guys suck. But they're
cool. They're fun to hang out with.
If I tell you I love them, I like,
I'm telling you these guys are,
there's something going on. And if you're
telling people that in your community,
a lot of the time they're really open
people too. You know what I mean?
That's well that plays a big role.
I think we could be, we thought,
we all thought that we had
issues with each other.
We were all thought like that somehow
or another you couldn't be athletic and
also like books. No. When you want
to talk to you about those books,
he couldn't be in the documentaries
but also be in the martial arts.
You couldn't do that.
You couldn't do that because you were
either like a meathead or you were a
nuanced person who wasn't worried
about physical activities.
Like you couldn't be both
like peop people. It's so,
I love that you just said because like
I play the fucking Banjo and violin and
people think we're a country band,
but we fucking rock like Ben plays the
electric guitar. It gets crazy and like,
but then we'll be sensitive.
And is it fair to say that you guys are,
because you're fair to say you guys
are a Donny and Marie for 2015 and Cho,
she's a little bit country. She's a little
bit, hold on, let me write that down.
That was a good fuck.
Come see you
could do is forced to them.
At first there were the
first fucking like, they were
kind of like a hybrid band.
They brother and sister though.
Mormon.
No, God, I'm so sorry
dude. From desert noises and
knock or his Roman. They are
on the hook. Me Jamie, pull up the,
the album of the Osman brothers.
Um, there was an Osman brothers album
where they did where they all showed their
planets that they have. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. When you die,
if you're a serious fucking hardcore
moment Mormon, you get your own planet.
Whoa. Oh, that's what's
up. We doing here. Why?
One of their albums is like them and
it shows like Mormon mythology on the
album, like planets and
shit. How does it go?
What that Jamie, it's a, you
get a planet when you die.
If I'm out of line, please. I need a five.
If I paraphrased pretty
sure the truth is coming.
Cause I remember somebody showed me to me,
it showed it to me and I almost blacked
out cause I always like, is this real?
I'm going to say something. I'm, you know
what, I'm not embarrassed about what?
I don't know. I couldn't name
a song. Maria. Oh, they had
a lot. And um, they were,
they were, they had a lot of hits. They're
very nice. But like Donnie especially,
it's like a really nice guy. He's
very friendly. He's like a super,
super like Nice,
easy going God that's awesome.
Like when you're around him and you know
like when I was a kid I used to watch
the, the Donny and Marie show on TV. So
I like to meet him in like real life.
I was like, is this real? Like I
totally didn't see a real like,
I mean Donny Osmond, I'm like, what is,
cannot really be Donny Osmond. There's
no way. I really hope after this we can,
this is a plan with Louis Marie.
This is,
it's called the plan apparently.
Which one from Seinfeld
where we,
we have some sort of an issue with our,
but did they have like a huge
radio hit? Yeah, they had,
well the Donny and Marie
had a big time show.
They had a big television show.
So it was more about the show.
It was like a one night,
a week variety show.
If I had to remember like correctly
dig deep into my memory banks,
but they would have like singers on
and they would sing. She would sing.
I'm a little bit contrary
and he would be like,
whoa, totally. Yeah. Like I
would have this thing. We're
kind of working together.
That's it,
dude.
I think it's the plan and this is the
inside of the album that has all sorts of
like going home with that hand.
Oh, the hand that holds the earth.
Is that what it is? Yeah, that's
the inside. Yeah. Hmm. Interesting.
Is that the home? But whatever it is,
that Mormon thing, whatever it is,
and made them, Made Donny Osmond
a very nice person. Very nice.
I mean that's kind of the stereotype.
I don't know if it matters.
Don't know if it matters.
I think in the end,
being, being a Nice Guy,
like Donny Osmond is more important
than knowing exactly how stars are made.
Knowing how planets are
formed in real life.
It doesn't really apply to the real world
because it's a super slow process and
if you dwell on that, you don't
have any time, there's no room.
You can't fit that in there. A
planetary question, can I ask you? Okay,
so I'm reading this book.
It's talking about all this
gas, all this matters. Boom,
colliding together and falling into
orbit of the sun and becoming this planet
that we're on. Right?
So why is there heat?
Why is there a ball of fucking
fire in the middle of it?
Where did super good question
from no idea. Me Neither.
I think it's like a fairy dust
and Leprechaun. Calm, loving
fairies and leprechauns each fuck a
separate tray and a calm Christ the death.
I'll take center of the Earth Texans to
change a light bulb because that one has
to watch the latter.
We don't lead light bulbs would
light candles around here.
Well, I have to go old school ride
horses, lot light candles, burning wax.
We drank whiskey
and we shoot and traders the dangerous
it can be really self aware worked.
This might be the most fucked up
we've ever been. Equally fucked us.
Last time I smoked weed and I was like,
Ooh,
you
just flat line for like when you smoke
me weed, it makes you introspective.
Um, I, it makes me, I'm an introvert,
a very introverted and uh, tired. Like,
I don't know. I'm not, I'm not
good at it, but also I'm not, but,
but it makes me sleep, which
is great because I have a
really hard time sleeping,
so I think that's something I have
them just like chemical reaction to it.
I've tried dude, I fuck you guys
are so good at it. You, you shine,
you really shine. Totally
understand where you're coming from.
You know who the fuck knows what it does.
I mean,
I know people that can't drink coffee.
Interesting. If they have a cup of coffee,
they feel like they're going to have
a heart attack. It just can't do it.
They just, for whatever reason,
coffee's really weird. Like I'll, I'll,
I'll have a cup and I will just like
peek and then I'll cry. Like if I,
if I have too much, I'll crash and they
get, they get really sad. But, but,
but like for like the two hours, I'm just
super productive like emails and shit.
Everybody does that. Are you
making fun of me? No, no, no, no.
If I knew how to put you in a
headlock, I would, but I think
that's the one that you do like a karate
chop. How do you protect the nose?
Put the turn your the back of the
hand towards the back of the head. No,
the other way. His head. You're choking.
Spin your hand like a left. Pinky down.
Pinky down. Keep going. Keep going.
Keep going. That make like karate.
Chop your hand. Make me cry.
Chop thing like you would cry.
Chop like straight hand right now.
That's what you're sneaking behind their
neck and then you squeeze down on that.
That's how you do it. I can fucking do
this. The hand on the back of the neck,
it goes into like a karate chop position
like this and what that does is gives
you maximum leverage.
If you do get under someone's arm,
you could totally choke a guy out asleep.
Hundred percent. God.
There's a lot of women,
like if it came to the difference between
like a woman who's like a kickboxer,
a defending herself.
It was the same amount of experience in
the gym as a woman who's a Jujitsu black
belt
defending herself. It would
be on my, um, in my opinion,
I would favor the woman like her ability
to dominate a much larger opponent
using only Jujitsu skills over,
uh, especially for women I think.
I think because Jiu Jitsu is the most
technical and the most a positional and
leverage based of all the martial
arts and it's sorta like I attributed,
I um,
uh,
compare it to like getting in an argument
with someone who doesn't know English
very well.
I'll give you were having an argument
with someone and they were like really
shitty at English and then we're
just slowly, you'd be like,
what the fuck are you talking
about, dummy? What'd you
say? Spit it out. Stupid.
Like it was a mean person.
You know yourself, right?
Well that's the same way with Jujitsu.
Like if you knew that the language of
you Jitsu so well and you had some dumb
dude that was trying to grab you,
you'd be like, yeah, fuck you.
They're like, you'd be like some crazy
Ninja chick on his back choking him.
Absolutely feasible. Whereas like with
striking, the real problem with that,
a lot of women phases,
the actual physical size of their bones,
like when you're punching her,
especially like unless you,
you have your hands fully
wrapped up like an, you know,
a good boxing wrap and then a
padded leather glove on top of that.
It's hard to just punch people
in the face if you're well,
unless you have a good sturdy jilled.
We're not like in a,
I'm not like in a position where I'm going
to have an actual battle with someone
yet you don't really know. I don't
know. You're right, but, but,
but at the end you want
to do it for competition.
You want to do it for self defense
defense. I mean like I would like to see,
then you can't say that because that
could happen on the way to the grocery
store. Oh my God. You run into
some crazy messed up chicks.
Do you get out? Literally
there's, there's something,
we're like, we're doing this. I
wish I had the fucking man power.
Literally to like we were in Nashville
like two weeks ago for Americana Fest.
We were playing this festival and we
were driving under this bridge and there
were these two guys beating the fuck
out of each other in the middle of the
street.
It was like a bottle over the face.
This one guy was choking the other guy
who tank or no, no. Hey look, terrible.
It was sloppy. It was sloppy. It
was sloppy. Crackhead bullshit.
It's one of the main puzzles but he was,
it was like,
obviously we called the police but like I,
I had this moment where I was like,
I wanted to do something. I'm
like, what the fuck can I do?
And I literally don't lean out the
window and I went stop at stop.
I didn't know what to do and I called
the police. But like if I were a new job,
like I would have definitely stayed
in my car. Right. Hundred percent
to me.
Listen to me,
if you fucking have your driving by
two people beating the fuck out of each
other, you are not there. Okay. You,
you were in a car.
Just because it's right in front of you.
That shit could be a hundred
miles in less and less.
There's someone in that
mixture that needs you.
Like if there's someone who's small and
they're getting beaten up by someone big,
then everything changes.
But if it's too fucking dudes you buy,
they're fighting this tree.
So my point is don't always stock,
just kiss already. Don't always stop.
Sometimes you gotta let two
dudes beat each of the day.
It's better for everybody.
Certain people, it's fine.
Just give them both rocks and
push them near the edge. Go
let them fall. Anything I do, I'm
going to stay and keep coal mining.
You got to keep moving.
Okay. Genes need to flourish.
They need to find better streams of of
diversity. I appreciate the [inaudible].
That's what I'm saying, man,
don't always stop fights,
but some fights you have
to stop. Right? Right.
The classic is a man beating
a woman, man. Being a woman.
There's a small battle in the front row
of the honey honey show the other day in
Long Beach. I don't like that.
I don't like that either,
but I also think it's amazing people
fucking look guys,
guys,
come on guys hug each other this
summer that we're fucking hardcore,
but also we're fucking lovers and like it
was like, it was amazing to have these,
these dudes were fighting and he was like,
fuck you mother fucker. And I was like,
guys, one of you as a honey honey
tee shirt. I just want to be like,
let's think about this for a second.
Here's her.
I hate that expression pro tip.
Whenever someone tells you that
they're hardcore, they're never harder.
That's 100% and like the expression,
we're hardcore,
but that never comes out of the mouth.
But Joe
just as hardcore,
no,
we'll never claim hardcore. I've never
claimed hardcore. I don't say it.
I'm more of like a medium core.
I'm balanced.
I'm all about longevity,
balance,
constant assessment of the path
and don't try to run the furthest.
Try to make sure you hit the least
trees. Nice. That's how I look at it.
I think it's like super.
It's super important to
evaluate the next few steps.
Well, I think there's a lot of
fucking continuing the same patterns.
They've got people into the positions
we're in now. A lot of flailing.
That's a great word too.
Perfect for it.
It sounds like what it looks
like flailing. No, it's true.
Right? Flailing. It's like one of
the best words ever. Descriptively.
That's a good one.
You fucking spastic a Taylor.
Damn, you got them right within us.
I take them down core, bro. You're
a flailing dude. You're flailing.
You just running, flailing
any crumble and they're like,
you're right.
I know.
It's definitely a word that like forces
you into a bad position, you know?
Sure. It's there. I
think that's how you, Oh,
you've got your footing. It's like
you're fucking falling out of control.
Let me hold you. I think conversations,
conversations are in a lot,
a lot of ways to like numerical exchanges.
Like you know,
you say something that's 30 and she goes,
oh this bitch wants to get crazy.
And she says something that's 37 and
then you might just rash here right up to
90 what in the 42 and 1670 but if we
take away the cultural context of the
words, she calls me and cut, my mother
told me, don't ever leave her crawl.
You will fucking cunt.
But girl cause you can't you stab
you stab her in front of your mother.
It's fucking to the death tax.
Conchas a big word but,
but what are those things?
What are those moments?
Well those really take away the cultural
contexts. There's a numerical value to,
to the expression like the
girl hit you with a 90 bomb.
Oh No,
that bitch tried to cut to the bone.
She tries to go through your own
emotions to get into your fucking nervous
system and start chiseling in their
fucking the PD that they occasionally,
but I think it's,
that's what it is.
If you look at it and not in terms of
like a conversation between two people
that are being mean to each other,
like w w throw all that stuff
away throughout all the, the, the,
the cultural framework that we have.
What are you watching? A number exchange.
You're watching people play in a
sound exchange to, you know, to keep,
I keep trying to fucking get it to sound.
It's a competition. It's a competition.
There's that,
there's a social competition involved
and people being mean to each other. Oh,
I really think that's what a lot
when when people's like, you know,
someone hits you with a 32 and you hit
him with a fucking 40 you know, like Whoa,
I walked away on a 40 you know,
and I was going to fucking keep going.
But so a nice clean kill,
there's a competition.
You'll go back to the water cooler.
You talk about it.
This fucking guy comes
up to me and he says,
well one day maybe you'll
be a manager to my pitch.
You don't think I know your fucking dad
owns the company or are you out of your
mind? If you want to live in
Milan, what are you talking about?
That he'll shut the door,
the lock,
the fucking lunch room and they'll
have these deep conversations.
I told this mother Fucker,
if your dad didn't on this company,
you'd be buried under my house.
People do. So they go through
them. But what are they doing?
Their number exchanging.
That's what they're doing.
They're to just try to win some
stupid social dominance. But then we,
we're okay with it's all
dynamic. Real what you, where
we had a big fight like last week,
took a long walk down,
thought I was going to take the train
to the next city and need me to travel
with it. You know, do
it. We'll go to Africa.
Can I be honest with you
about something? Um, this
is fucking you guys following me around
because I hate, you know, but it's,
it's true. You know, it's something,
the numbers game, I have a
temper for sure. You know,
and um, some triggers as to you,
you know, but we all have tempers.
It just takes different things.
The main maintenance of this band that
we're in requires a certain frequency.
You're fucking favorite word today.
Um, that if we don't, if we don't,
if we don't exist in that,
there can be an imbalance and then it
can build into this fight and then we'll
fucking fight. Cause we're in
a fucking band. But, but like,
cause we were two people that spent so
much time together and go through all
these incredible experiences,
but there's a certain finish
each other's sandwiches.
There's the stress that comes along
with it. You know what I mean? Dude,
you're traveling, you're doing
shows or just live in whatever.
But my relationship with the comedians
that I work with is less intimate because
we don't share us. We very, very, very,
very rarely share a
stage at the same time.
And we don't have to practice
together. And we, you know, it's,
it's a totally different experience
I think cause it's a, it's an,
it's like you guys,
if you have a bunch of friends that
you consistently tour with, you know,
that were nodding your band.
Like it's very talk about numbers.
I'm having the right combination
of people in cause we're in a,
we're in a a used Cadillac Escalade
2007 this is all good romance novels and
there's room for about four
people save for a girlfriend.
Every once in a while our drummers
girlfriend comes out or possibly are.
I know she's great. She's very sweet. Joe.
Joe,
don't do that.
I'm sure you're a wonderful person. If
you're listening, not talking about, oh,
I couldn't possibly be talking about you.
I don't know you.
And they haven't said nothing wrong.
Covered.
You have this like combination
of personal space and then
she's trying to read my text.
This is my side of the bus. You wouldn't
even be here if you want honey, honey.
She jokes. I'm just joking. No,
but it's funny because like we fucking,
we will fight and then we'll have these
great experiences. Like where were you?
Just you, you have to like work
your, it's like we're all married.
Everyone in the band.
You know,
it's like you spent so much time together
to this point where like I know by the
way that Ben Breathe
sometimes that like, oh he's,
he's really fucking mad,
or he needs a sandwich. Or like
creating drama with your fake psychic
powers of psyche,
psyche,
please,
please, please listen, please. You
guys need more people to bounce off of.
You need to get annoyed at
me every now and then. Tell
him that fucking guy to just turn it off.
Turn it off. No more jokes, no more fun.
We have good dosing.
You know what I mean?
We see each other every couple of months.
I honestly think it's lucky meatloaf
every day when you're with the same person
every day,
like you want to meet new people and do,
but you guys are achieving something
that you couldn't achieve if you just in
this like crazy life where
you went one way and you do.
You guys got this weird thing going
on because you have this weird,
you have this,
you have this artistic synergy.
I would say in that like you're
both very different, but you,
you were also very, you're,
you're very cool to each other.
Like as much as you guys get in fights,
like when you guys are nice to each other,
like I can see like when you
guys interact that you're,
you genuinely love each other
and you genuinely friends.
And if you do say something
a little mean every,
occasionally you're genuinely sorry and
you genuinely care and love about it.
You love each other.
So when you guys do,
it comes out that comes out in your music.
You guys aren't you,
you're not day players on a fucking
sitcoms pretended to be in love with each
other. You know what I'm saying? I mean,
you guys aren't like a fucking guys
that studio musicians, they brought it,
never met each other and they're
going to lay down a track.
Now you guys have been doing
this and you have like this,
this thing you're doing together. You
know, this, this, this. You're all,
you have to deal with the fact that you're
so intimate with each other like you,
you, you're going to annoy the fuck
out of each other. You are each other.
I mean you guys are fucked up.
You can totally numb with your lives.
If it gets too crazy,
you totally could,
but right now you can't cause right
now you're like almost one person.
You guys are almost like one like
really well spread out person.
You just saved me so much money
in therapy. I can't even tell you.
I'm glad because I can't afford it.
It's too good.
It's still good together because
you're too good together.
It wouldn't work like that with other
people. It's, it would be different.
It would probably be equally
awesome for both of you,
but don't let it happen because what you
guys have right now, you've hit this,
whatever this thing is,
you've got this ball of focus
and experience and musical
knowledge and love and
it's all coming together with your own
specific creativity and you guys are just
in, you're putting out these songs that
are like, Whoa, like they're not there.
They keep getting better, like your,
your shit keeps getting better.
Like you have your old stuff was awesome
and then you new stuff like grows and
some of you putting layers on these
things. So look, you got to be friends,
do ecstasy every few months past the
move and every like eight or nine months,
just set a weekend aside where no one
is going to touch their cell phone.
Just do a little Molly. It sounds
like you're joking, but honestly,
really beautiful things and, and it's,
it's something that, uh, is nice to hear.
Thank you for saying that. You know,
it's a weird life. We live in jazz.
It's fuck is a lot of instability
and you know, but like we,
it's funny like when we fight,
when we go to our separate corners and
if it lasts a while, like it's weird,
there's like a real darkness, but it's
weird. But it's also part of our dynamic,
you know? And it's, I think that's part
of all what you're saying. You know,
you can't exclude certain parts of it.
Yeah.
And if you guys had some sort
of a specific relationship,
like if you are brother and
sister or be so many houses,
same parents,
those parents fostered and they
created us and now we were children.
And this is this our, this is my
cousin, this is my cousin Ben. Yeah,
here's a mom who's my brother, sister.
And that's why we're friends, you know?
But when your family with someone
who you're not really family with,
like I'm family with a lot of people
and not all of them are related to me.
I'm family with a giant group of people.
You guys are clearly family.
You guys are family. So whatever
happens, like you have to,
you have to hear, you're always going to
have to deal with that. It's just not,
it's not find, you know what I'm
saying? Yeah. P. Dot. Husband and wife,
you're not mother and son.
You know, it's, it's weird.
You're not father and daughter.
You're not brothers.
What's the noise I need to make
with my face? That means you got,
and if you don't have that noise,
oh, you guys aren't married. Well,
how do you think he's ever going to
come in? You know like those fucking,
the people go through that kind of shit
and relationships with like just what,
what noise do I have to make the changes?
Your perception of what this
is cause what we have to,
it has to be defined
and then what the fuck?
What's the definition of a band of really,
really close friends?
They make awesome music together.
What does that, what does that,
what does that do you guys to wizards?
Wizards. Plague it. What the fuck are you,
you travel all across the
country together. Okay.
What do I call you when I call you guys
or you guys? Accountants. Gandalf gains.
Are you married? Is it
a mister and missus? No.
Is it a non gender specific designation
of some sort of Congrat contractual
agreement? Like what is it? What is
it? Oh, we're just in the van together.
We love each other.
What the fuck is this like angel,
man that came into our lives or something.
I don't fucking know.
And you guys to me,
I remember when the first time I watched
your video when you guys did that angel
of Death Acoustic version on the roof.
I was like Whoa.
A while ago. We wouldn't know each other
a long time. Now who's the dude's name?
It was a crazy name that told me about
it on the Internet. Balls of steel
still. We don't know who that is. He knows
superhero who has this knowledge.
He's definitely love.
I've had a few people,
you know,
it's one of the cooler things about being
connected to people on social media.
They'll,
they'll connect you with something that
you probably never would have heard of
before. It's amazing. And
then just for you guys,
we became friends, you know,
in a strange way. So that's
it. Yeah, it's been amazing,
man. We are headed, coldly
changed. Um, our band honestly,
like it changed us from being a, we can
throw the country now honestly, and it's,
this has been a huge
part of it. Huge. Wow.
This is the way I look at
like all podcasts. Honestly.
It's like the idea of taking credit for
the ocean when you accidentally stumbled
upon an opening that turned something
into a river. Like that's what,
that's what I get.
All everything that everybody extracts
out of what they find on the Internet is
essentially like you found a path,
he hit a button,
you pull the lever and a river
open. You know, there's a ribbon,
a river of honey honey songs
or Sturgill Simpson or,
or Tom Segora or Joey Diaz.
You're like some guys trying to take
credit for the ocean because you figured
out this, if you hit this
switch, it opens it in the river,
just runs into the villages and then
everybody finds out about Duncan Trussell
keep hitting these switches and like,
so I can't take any credit for it.
Oh,
all I did was stumble upon some,
some switching station for all these uh,
like super talented people. Yeah.
That's how I look at it. Yeah.
But it's a cool thing that you're
looking for switching stations.
Not even though I think it's what's fucked
up movie. Yes and no. You totally are
pretty pertinent purpose for
where we're at right now.
It's pretty cool and it's really
great to witness the effort,
the effects of what you do and at the
switching station when we're out on the
road and all these incredible,
incredible fucking people that come out
that like just love you and and really
learn from the things that you say.
You know
they love you guys too.
So many had the flower honey honey shirt
at one of my shows you the night the
grandma flower. I have
that tattooed. It's a duo.
Shazamm you want me to dues? We're
going to freeze frame that and jerk off.
That's fucked. No time. Let's just
move on how it works. No worries.
You feel funny but kind of in a good way.
No,
I haven't decided to make a good
connection with the nice people online.
It's like one of the most promising like
hints at what's possible for the future.
Like there's this idea that because
online is anonymous and anonymous means
you're always going to be mean.
That's not the case.
Like you're always going to get a certain
amount of people that are shitheads.
But those people, quite
honestly, almost all of them,
they're damaged and hurt people who got
fucked over in life and then they try to
take out all that
on all these other people.
I mean that's the vast
majority of what's going on.
But the amount of noise per
capita is so high amongst cunts.
It's hot so hard.
Cause most people don't post anything.
Most people would think
you guys are awesome.
We've listened to his podcast
who've listened to your song.
If they don't say a word about it, they
don't tweet about it. They don't. They'll,
they'll come up to me at shows
and I'll just tell me, oh my God,
thank you guys for introducing
me to honey, honey. Oh,
all the time. All the time.
All the time. Awesome. They don't
say, they don't ever say, you know,
I tweet about them all the time.
No, the people that are too sweet,
they'll say like mean shit.
Well, you know, it's a free,
it's funny when you talk about like
damaged people and stuff like we,
we have a song called bad people that like
of that song. Thanks man. But you know,
it, it, it came from this
fascination with like,
why are people so mean?
Why are people doing shitty things?
Like why do you bust a car window and
steal somebody's shit? Why do you,
why you should, why do you all that?
That's one one way. But like, why,
why you sinister? Why are
you, where are you, you know,
poisoning the cats in my neighborhood.
Like there's this,
this fascination with where
that fucking comes from. Right.
And we wrote that song
and like, it, it was, it,
it was just kinda hanging out for a while.
It was really like thinking about
it for a long time, you know, just,
just why, how, when do you turn
or you born that way? Did you,
were you born into it like,
because bad people come from
Nice families all the time and,
and incredible people come from
fucking shit holes. You know,
they crawl out of a hole, but I don't know
if there's any one answer to it, but I,
I, I just, all I can say is that there's
a fascination with where it comes from.
I don't know.
What do you think is more,
more common?
Do you think it's more common for really
nice people to come out of total shit
hole environments or for really nice
families to have an asshole for a kid?
I think that,
yeah,
inspiration can hit someone
at edit an incredible, um,
like phenomenal rate when you
just don't even expect it.
I think,
um,
you can have information just like slammed
upside your head in like an instant
and it could be the littlest thing.
And I don't know.
I know that I'm privileged
families there have, um,
they, they have a, a comfort that,
that unprivileged families don't
have. Right. You know, and there's a,
there's just a completely
different perspective on
need and hunger and emotional
hunger. You could be emotionally
starved in any scenario. You could be,
you know what I mean?
Shape so much of who we
are. You know, and you,
you can have a bad experience in any
context. It doesn't matter if you, um,
you know, what's your, I don't
know, your social statuses.
You can solve a bad experience, you know,
and it can still shape you and sure.
What do we value? You know, we,
I think in general we have pot,
good values,
things to be excited about.
We value kindness and generosity
and things like, so it's rare
to see someone,
I don't know if I necessarily believe it
that someone who comes out of a series
of good experiences just boom,
we'll do things unless there's
serious psychological malfunctioning.
It's like you're going to treat people
as a reflection of your environment for
sure. What I think, I think we also have
this need to say it's this or it's that,
you know, it's, it's a disease
or it's a, it's its DNA or it's,
it's never that clear cut and dry.
I think there could be a lot of factors
and I think a lot of factors in your
environment and especially
your experience, they can
kind of push your genes,
they can push the chair person of
getting genetically whatever it was.
Those two things that weren't even
taught to you. Like, you know,
like your anger or your addiction
or whatever. And you know,
I think at the end of the day,
like everybody's got their suitcase and
we need to respect everybody suitcase
because like,
what might be a shitty day for me,
it could be like the worst day for
somebody or, or vice versa. You know,
you never know what someone's volume
level of their, their, you know,
capacity for stuff isn't. And you've got
to respect that, you know, like I'm like,
Oh man, um, I, I don't want
to get, but like I had a bad
day with blah, blah, blah,
and like, someone's like, Oh yeah, my
father killed my sister, you know, like,
you don't know. And that could be
their first day. And I'm like, Oh man,
I thought my day was bad.
But at the end of the day,
like everyone has a different volume of
what they're capable of experiencing and
if you're not capable of experiencing
it, you'll die. You know?
Like you're just like,
you have as much as you can take and
then if you can't take it, you're like,
that's, that's what your tie, it's like,
what are you, you know, what are you,
if you're not experiencing
anything and if you're not dead,
we just alone silent in a room. You'd
like that lady that kill halls people.
Then the left or on the castle,
that was her suitcase.
That was the suitcase she had to carry.
Yeah. If you're not experiencing anything,
you're barely alive though. That's
one of the tricks of being a person.
If you're not experiencing things, if
you, if you're not having ups and downs,
that's what you've got to go outside
your comfort zone. Get Weird.
You don't want to Austin, don't do
that. Don't buy one of those shirts.
Keep Austin weird. Keep
Portland Weird. Don't do it.
I know, and it's not your fault.
If you were about to buy it,
go on this fucking shirt.
Rule. I was going to buy.
Yeah.
If you've never seen it before and if
you're really young and you have a head
injury
was just kidding about the head injury.
These are chokes. If you're,
if you're a young person,
you don't know how ridiculous
it is to have a shirt on.
It says keep Austin Weird.
Yeah,
it's the same font and every shirt and
it pretends it's hand written eight
involved in a bad way. At one point
it meant something really important.
Not really because the people that
were crying about Portland weird
were fake weird. All of them. Every
one of them. They're all twats.
The real weird people, they shut the
fuck up and stay weird. They stay weird,
you know,
fucking protests.
They don't want to get together
and make a Facebook page.
Keep Austin weird sign up here. If
you agree, thumbs up or thumbs down.
What's Joe? It's not. It's not.
They're only here because of sister
markets. See The hipster trap,
there would be no hipsters if they
had a forge for their own foods. None.
Supermarkets.
You think the hipster trap is a bear
trap and in the middle in the middle is
like a six pack of PBR. A pack of
American Spirit Lights in like ray bans.
Okay.
They should do the same thing,
but with Kale and alkalized water
veganic make sure it speak on it and the
goodwill cowboy.
I love all those things.
Ps love me a good. I like thrift
store cowboys, snap button shirt.
Well I think the, the, the inclination
behind being and hipsters good.
It's like they want to be,
they want to be above the stupid shit
they see every day. That's moron.
It can pedantic, is that the word? No.
If you want to get down to brass tacks,
I sure did.
You know,
I'm really trying to embrace my Midwestern
roots and just fucking go with it.
You know? It's just no my
wrath tech I'm talking about,
but you're totally,
you're already covered it make me want
to get Fargo on Netflix, first of all.
I'm not that far west. It's more
like, oh my God, go rounds. You know?
It's just like, it's not as like don't
share. No, it's not like more eastern.
It's more of an eastern, more
Rochester, a little less disgusting.
A little more books. It's still that
sexy. Let's call a spade a spade here,
and if you can get them out of there,
it become sexy.
It's the willing to take a
chance. Joe, you're so happy
to teaching ballet. I got to get
out of this fucking town. Actually.
She's on the rock and roll tour bus. Ooh.
Hanging out with the first black guy.
No, no. I brought, I brought us to
sit down. I was like, wait, I'm lost.
Listen, we just did three fucking
hours of a single song and that's,
that's not going to happen to you though.
So what we're going to do,
since you guys are, look, I know how you
think. This is what we're going to do.
This is no time for trials.
We don't have to saying we could
just talk me to do it. We're gonna.
We're take a bathroom break. Exactly. See,
and then we'll come back and we'll do
a second podcast where we talk way less
shit did we do okay? Awesome.
We made a bunch of quarter
to seven though, right? Yeah,
we got about 20 minutes.
We've got 20 minutes,
but I think it'd be better if we did two
different podcasts. I think it's cool.
We should definitely do that in
both podcasts, especially the ones,
but they get to see how
good you guys are now.
And the new video, let me
keep talking about on the
treadmill right now. You fuck.
I've been running for two hours and
20 man, I don't to use talk. Oh,
Joe Rogan make them saying
shit. Okay, bad about this.
This is all super positive.
That's good.
So we'll take a little
pee break for a second.
You were going to take a pee break and
we're going to come back and we got to
come back with a completely different
podcasts in a totally mellow vibe.
We're going to do is we're going to do
what Americans in 2015 called hug it out.
Ooh. Hugs. We total.
And we're going to prepare for
the next hour, the next hour.
We're just going to have a good time,
right?
So this is the onus footage coming up.
You fucking monsters.
We'll see soon. Alright, bye. Bye.